Actually,
I'm a
double date tonight.
Oh.
Oh and we'll live if you're looking for something to do in Hollywood tonight at
the comedy store.
Brian Red Pen.
Oh,
he's right here.
He has a big show tonight.
Big Show.
Big Show at the comedy store.
Jim Florentine.
Fucking hilarious.
Dom.
I rera Jesus fucking Christ.
Then Glebe.
Steve,
I don't know how to pronounce his last name,
but she's hilarious.
A g.
He's fucking hilarious.
But I always ruin his last name.
Dean del Rey,
fresh off of a fucking motorcycle accident.
The kid can't be stopped.
Brian Moses,
Jesus fucking Christ.
What a line up.
Brian red band.
Mike Lawrence,
Tony Fucking Hinchcliffe marks Sarah Tele and secret guest.
Two of them,
which I know which are national headliners and very hilarious guys.
Well,
I can't say if it's a guy or a girl.
One of them was fucking famous as shit,
but apparently this bitch is too big to have her name put on the,
I say bitch,
with all due respect and reference,
the Dama rare.
What?
All due respect,
it's tonight at eight 30 at the comedy store.
Main Room.
Tickets are only 10 bucks on sale right now.
Yeah,
they're on Brian's Twitter or they're on my Twitter and if you go to the comedy
store.com you can buy the tickets.
Fucking Sebastian speaking a comedy store over here and what's happening.
Nice to be here.
You and I have been friends for a long fucking time.
My friend.
I remember when you first started 1998 you were very am very
prevalent at the comedy store.
When I first came there.
You were right.
You were there every night and then you left and now you're back.
Yeah.
I love it back,
man.
I'm,
I'm having a great time.
I think this is the golden age of that place.
I'm fucking amazing now,
right?
Compared to some of the Times that we shared there when,
uh,
2000,
2001,
I was a young fledgling comedian and a
snake skin.
See through shirts.
You definitely had a very interesting style,
like a Long Island club style.
I was trying to bring the nightclub scene to the stage.
That's what I guess it was.
I tried that once.
I mean,
didn't you ever go through like,
I got to have an outfit?
Yeah.
What was your own?
My first time on stage.
This is how retarded I am.
Uh,
not just my first time at first three or four times I tried to dress like a
comedian from that movie punchline,
you know,
like I would wear like the sneakers with a dentist,
like a jacket,
like a blazer,
but with the sleeves rolled up and maybe a wacky tee shirt or I had a wacky pin,
like a pin with a smiley face with a bullet hole in his head or something.
Oh.
So embarrassing.
When I stop and think about what a fucking tool I was,
you know,
but I used that said the normal kind of,
but how was wearing Melrose avenue snake skin?
See seethrough where you could see my nip.
You were too.
I remember it.
This isn't bullshit.
You would wear some of the wackiest shit.
Yeah,
it was,
it was awful.
It was trying to find my footing,
you know?
I was just trying to be different than a,
yeah,
I had to go through that stage.
Right.
Was that all your idea or did you have a manager that,
no,
this is all me.
I came up with these marketing scheme
when I first came out to Los Angeles.
I was coming from Chicago and I come from a family where my father was a
hairdresser and my mother was a secretary.
Nobody's in the entertainment business.
So I'm like,
how am I going to crack into this?
So what I did was I went and I took some modeling shots off the express way and
some weeds.
This is professional shots and wheat.
Yeah,
I did the,
um,
I don't know if he ever did the,
uh,
like Barb has sign modeling thing where you heard it on the radio.
If you think you got it,
come down and Oh yeah,
I did that.
So I went in,
I took my photos,
I brought him home.
My mother's like that.
The photos.
Beautiful.
You got to send this out.
This is,
Holly was going to love this salt.
What I did was I shrank it down into like a four by six and at the time they had
at Photoshop on the back you could uh,
you could uh,
there was like a bunch of people watching a movie screen.
So in the movie scream you could type tax.
So I typed in coming this summer Sebastian go like it was a movie.
I didn't put any phone number.
I figured I'm just gonna I'm just going to wet their beak with the photo.
This is how sick I was.
So I'm thinking the casting directors are going to get it and go.
Oh and then he didn't leave a number.
So when I got to la I sent out another batch and it said now playing in Los
Angeles with the phone number,
now I'm one phone call,
one call zero is it?
That was my entree I want,
it felt like there was at least one doc that trying to fuck you.
If I was a sleazy,
the
casting director and I was of the gay inclination of the year,
my fucking kind of guy,
terrific bite.
Not Teachers that gave bike seat through snakeskin shirt.
Fucking,
hey man,
this is my guy.
I have a waiting for him to call.
Terrible.
I went,
uh,
I went on stage one weekend,
one of the worst times ever bombed in my life.
There was a buff,
a bunch of factors that led to this bombing,
but I'm one of them that I was dressed up like I was going out to a club and a
I,
there's like the first time I'd ever done it,
like I had cavalry cheese.
You remember cavalry cheese,
they were like tight at the top and they kind of ballooned out a little bit in
the legs.
Very nice.
I had like a nice shirt button up look good.
I had hair back then and I was on stage and just fucking eat and plates of Shit.
And then I remember was like being so uncomfortable with the way I was dressing
and bombing.
I went on have to brewer.
It was like one of them.
It was one of the pivotal moments of my young career.
I'd only been doing comedy like
I got to say like three years maybe.
And I was headline and really shit.
I've been headline and really didn't have the time.
It's just bullshit.
I was,
I bullshitted my way into position and I kind of pulled it off until Saturday
night,
late night show,
Saturday late night show brewer went up and lit the fucking place on fire.
I mean,
he crushed like I'd never seen any comic crush before.
Up until that moment.
It was just like Jesus.
I was terrified backstage.
Fucking terrified.
Just didn't know how to follow anybody back then.
Didn't know how to laugh at it and just ride the wave and have fun.
Just it went up there and eight plates a shit.
But part of it was definitely,
I was super uncomfortable with the way I was dressed.
I was like,
what am I doing?
But where are you wearing that offs where you were a caviar,
ICI guy,
or did you just figure it out?
How I was trying to get laid,
I guess I probably would have.
I didn't know what the fuck I was doing.
I was so lost.
I would wear whatever works.
You know when you're trying to get laid and you're a young guy,
you fucking wear whatever they like.
The clothing is entirely dictated by the success.
Like women's appeal,
like what women find appealing.
That's what we wear.
Whatever the fuck they does.
The reason why the fanny pack,
this is why people can't wear fanny packs.
My beloved fanny pack right here,
see I'm married and I could pull that shit off.
If you're not trying to get laid,
you can wear that fucking thing.
Or if you don't give a fuck,
if you get divorced,
you can wear that thing.
But if you,
if you're a guy,
if you're a young guy hoping to impress the Gao and you walk around with a
fucking bag bolted to your waist,
you know,
you get aware of what they want you to wear this.
It's all dictated by women fashion.
If it was just man on the planet,
there would be no fucking designer shoes.
They would be,
there would be nothing.
There would be nothing.
We don't be wearing skins.
We'd all be wearing animal skins or whatever the fuck is comfortable.
Cotton shit shorts.
Nobody would give a fuck if there was no women.
If it was just removed from the equation,
if no longer,
if there was no like not only were there no women,
like we didn't need to reproduce.
People live forever and every guy that's here is going to be here forever.
That's it.
This is the,
these are the people done.
It would be the fashion industry would tank.
It would go crashing down to the ground so quick.
But does your wife have any say in what you wear and like Joey,
you want to put like a button up on?
If we go out she will ask me to wear something nice.
If we go out,
like if we're going out to a nice dinner somewhere and we'll do like a date
night gold,
nice little restaurant.
We've been lately going to these Michelin rated restaurants.
You ever do that?
You go look and find,
oh is a Michelin rated one.
Oh it's a five star one and you go to these place.
If you're go to those,
they still have miscellaneous.
It is worth going because it's all those crazy foodie people that give you ever
met a real foodie,
like a legit Foodie,
you know,
like they'll tell you like where the spots are and we have some friends that are
like,
so like Brian Cowen knows all the spots.
Callen and his wife are like legit foodies.
Callan is like,
he's a legit foodie in no legit wine connoisseur.
Like he really knows.
I just remember shit.
I like try to pick stuff that's expensive.
That's 100 bucks.
It's got to be good.
You know what I mean?
It's like,
it can't be terrible and but Callen those like where it's from.
What part of frost that grow the great.
He'll tell you how the grapes are fucking different than the other grapes,
but these restaurants,
then we go to one of those.
Like she'll ask me,
I have to wear shoes.
I have crocodile shoes,
I crocodile skin shoes and fucking ideas.
What else?
Come out on initial and nights.
Yeah,
I won the other night.
Double Doubleday with calendar.
His wife.
I'm a fucking gators on woo looking slick dude.
I'm telling you.
Is it something that you're aware that your wife hates every time you were like,
do you have like a six those barbell jeans,
those jeans that I have,
they're,
they're elastic cache there.
Fucking totally.
They're rubber jeans.
They're fucking elastic.
They look like jeans,
right?
Yeah.
But like,
but when you pull them,
they'll like this.
They'll like this cloth.
They look exactly like jeans.
Like I worry I'm on stage all the time.
But they don't bind you at all.
The companies send them to me.
Well there's a bunch of companies and diesel makes them now a lot of them,
but they,
they don't make them with as much elastic as barbell.
The barbell is this shit.
Those are like fucking,
there is no resistance.
It's like,
like your legs can,
you can do full splits in them.
No problem at all.
You can,
you kick somebody in the head wearing those,
you wouldn't have any resistance.
Does not like them because they're not real.
This stick looking Nicholas get girls don't like,
they don't like,
and we find out you wearing rubber stretch jeans,
Robert Jan,
you can
find out you're fucking nuts.
But it's wearing them the mock him.
Sam,
is your husband still wearing those jeans?
Has He wearing yoga fans to you guys go out and he wears yoga pants.
So they're like yoga pants in gene form.
They're not that tight.
But
I have another pair that she fucking hates.
I only,
I think she hides him cause I can't find them.
They have a drawstring,
they have a like they tie at the top and she's like,
those are fat people.
Parents.
And I go,
well first of all,
you fat shaming.
Okay,
second of all,
if you are not overweight,
I am.
I'm not an overweight person.
So if I'm wearing these,
will you give a fuck if I'm wearing fat people jeans,
you know.
But to her like the fact that they have a string that you tie the top is
embarrassing.
Yeah,
I know.
No strings,
strings button.
Right then it works.
He was tying your clothes.
Forget it.
Yeah,
but why is that?
Oh No,
I got a few draw strings in the closet and nothing wrong with that.
Draw string jeans or listen,
I'm not up to the rubber gene.
That's a whole other deal.
All the companies are making them now.
I see him on the street like there's a big billboard the other day for this
other kid.
I think it really makes a pair of them.
Diesel makes him now.
Well then I got to look into it though.
Can do it.
I'm telling Ya go down Melrose.
Next time you're on one of those mad shopping,
you gotta eat bags over your shoulder.
That Melrose Street is a strange environment.
Well,
in the night in 1998 I used to live on that street,
used to go to all those stores and then they all kind of close,
so now it's going through kind of a weird resurgence,
so they don't really have those,
those leopard nipple shirts
now know every time I go by it's like a new store that's opened up a new coffee
shop.
Why a skateboarding shirt stores and things like that.
Did you see that skateboarding video that I posted on Instagram yesterday or
Youtube yesterday?
We played it on the show yesterday because we had a woman that had suffered from
a severe head trauma.
This fucking kid is going 70 miles an hour down a road in Colorado.
He's gotten this super deep,
steep hill and he's just talked like a skier,
like one of those speed skiers and he's fucking flying and it's just,
oh,
your hands get clammy,
your feet start twitch and you're like,
oh Jesus.
How Jesus saw Jesus.
Watch it when you get a chance.
I've seen one of those.
It was two guys though,
and they were going nuts.
If you wipe,
if you wipe,
you are so fucked when rock.
Yeah.
Anything.
Well,
I think they're probably pretty good at balance.
Like they could probably pick it up pretty good.
But this motherfuck area right there,
look at this crazy fucker filming it.
Probably a car.
I would imagine a car,
which is how they know he's going 70 miles an hour.
That's a very good question though.
Could be another asshole behind them.
It's also doing the same thing.
If he hits a rock,
the car's gonna kill him.
That's a very good question.
That's a very good point though.
Well,
he'll go forward.
It's not like if he hits a rock,
he's gonna stop dead in its tracks.
He's going 70 miles an hour.
I don't know if you know a little thing about call it nurture.
You know the car's not going to know it's gonna hit a rock,
but the car,
he will not go that much slower is what I'm saying.
He's gonna fly forward.
If he,
if he wipes,
the guy's going to hit the brakes and he's going to go,
he doesn't have any breaks like so he's going to skid and remove all of his
skin.
When you ever seen someone who's gotten mad road rash,
did you see dean Delray?
He posted on his Instagram,
his whole side.
It just skimmed off all his tattoos on his arms where he skinned his arms,
hurt his tattoos look brand new now because it just took a layer of skin off and
so it looks like he just got his tattoos again.
Was it like,
you know how you're,
you're exfoliating
tattoos fade,
just get in a car accident.
Somebody hit him going 70 miles an hour,
a tweaker I suppose they car jacked a car and had accomplished following her.
She hits Dean going 70 miles an hour,
gets out of her car,
gets in the other car and takes off.
How does he know she was going 70 miles an hour?
He was just guessing because she,
he was going about 65 or so,
and then he saw her coming up behind them in the rear view,
like just going crazy fast.
And he,
she,
he said that he was,
she was going so fast,
he didn't have a chance to like get out of the way or anything.
He,
she just went right into him.
How does he know she's a tweaker?
Uh,
no,
it was a carjacking so most likely he's lucky.
He's okay,
but he was going on stage tonight.
Yeah.
He's forgetting the super cars going to get a hero's welcome tonight.
He was at the comedy store last night and,
uh,
you said,
see how many people were like,
oh,
are you okay?
I'm doing the Pat.
If you get a new tattoo,
that's the first fucking thing
people do.
They slapped that tattoo.
They can't even help it.
I think it's like a magnet thing.
I think people are attracted to your injury.
Yeah.
But he's supposedly quitting a motorcycles,
which is interesting.
He said he got out of it is get out of jail free card or whatever.
So He's,
he's looking at a Volkswagen right now.
Wow.
Good for him.
Yeah.
It's a scary thing,
man.
Scary thing.
You're like a thrill seeker motorcycle.
Don't you have a motorcycle?
I'm fucking torn.
I'm like a half of two different people.
I'm fucking terrified of everything and I do a lot of dangerous shit.
But no,
I don't have a motorcycle.
I came close,
but,
uh,
I was actually going through the motorcycle safety course,
the whole deal with a couple buddies of mine that still ride my buddy Peter
Hirsh co he's still riding.
Um,
but when we were doing it to people I know wiped bad.
That was when Frank Meir,
who was the UFC heavyweight champion at the time,
got hit by a car.
He,
it's,
they snapped his femur.
This guy,
a old man ran a red light to spaced out raw,
just fucking nailed him,
sent him flying 70 feet through the air.
He soared 70 feet in the air from a car and his,
and he's a g Frank's at giant dude and his leg snapped in half and he wasn't the
same for like,
like a year and a half,
two years.
Took a long time for him to recover.
That scared the shit out of me.
And then my friend Ed's and fell and just tore his shoulder up and uh,
he,
his shoulder's fucked up and you know,
that was it for me.
And then another person I know saw somebody hit,
I saw somebody got hit the other day.
I didn't see the hit,
but I saw him after it was over and he was screaming in agony.
Line on is on the ground.
They had like the car beside him,
his bike was like,
ah,
ah
yeah,
you hear all these things about,
I got a,
I got a scooter,
a pop around town with the scooter and the,
and then you start seeing stuff like this and they're like,
maybe we should give the scooter at rest.
But I gotta tell you if the driver on in La and his scooters is,
I mean it's shave some time off and park right in.
Oh yeah.
And bounce out.
But uh,
you know,
you don't think anything's going to happen,
but then you hear someone like this with the car jacking and then you're,
so I think the best move for those things is when you're on the highway and it's
bumper to bumper and those mother fuckers are cutting the lane because people at
home were,
I don't know where you live and you'll listen to this,
but in la for some strange reason,
you're allowed to drive in between cars.
Legally.
It's super fucking dangerous.
Like when I lived in Boston,
people used to do it,
but it was illegal and people would get mad when people did it.
But here.
It's totally,
yeah.
I had some friends who came out and visit and one of the first things that they
said was like,
dude,
everybody's breaking the law on the highway.
The motorcycles,
Mike,
they're not like,
that's the law.
You're allowed to do that here.
And they just looked at me like that.
What was crazy when I first saw it,
I was like,
what?
They can almost clipped my mirror.
My Mirror has been clipped.
My Mirror is still fucked from a motorcycle guy doing really clipping my mirror.
Yeah,
he's lucky.
He's alive.
I mean,
you imagine you're,
you're fucking man.
Those Ducati crazy fuckers.
Hi Bussa dudes.
Yeah.
He didn't even stop.
I don't think he knows.
I was driving home from the comedy store wants and was one of those gangs of
motorcycles.
You know,
you get like 30 40 guys out riding and one motherfucker is doing a wheelie for
like a half a mile and he's going fast.
He's just
just to just barreling down the highway cars all around them and he's doing a
wheelie and all I could think of was this fucking dude goes down.
He's a dead man and we're all going to see it.
We're all going to see cars rolling over his head.
But my bump bump,
yeah,
I mean I guess it's exciting.
Now.
Must be a thrill.
Oh,
it's a rush.
You get that scooter up to 35.
See I think that that's a good idea cause I live in
Burbank and that wouldn't be bad to just like go to the store,
you know,
go to,
do little
things here and there.
You should know when those hovercrafts that got Wiz Khalifa arrested.
Yeah.
Can one of those things.
I like the dude.
How's it?
The store can't do it.
Right.
Those are great.
Hate how like just going into the bank and there's people standing on this
things and really seen a lot of it everywhere.
Every other word you would,
you would drive around on those things.
Okay.
Fuck it.
We'll go to Ralph's and yeah,
rubber jeans,
your liquid,
your leopard nipple.
You tell me what you bought that shirt.
I'll wear that.
That's what my new outfit,
Dat and the Hover board.
I think that,
uh,
you know they're going to make them illegal.
So like right now,
like when you're driving around in a supermarket with those things,
you can get away with it because there's no law.
Did you hear what happened?
The guy that's on shark tank,
they're the rich billionaire guy.
He actually owns the patent for all those and all those are just generic
replicas of the original that are sent from Korea.
So all these ones you see around or just rebranded generic like shitty once.
So he's going,
all right,
everyone stop selling these.
Now I own the patent.
You all owe me money.
So he,
he's this,
he's raking it in because of those things.
Oh No.
So he owns a patent.
So he put a stop on all these people showing up.
Generic ones have to stop.
And what's probably going to happen is he's probably going to raise the price of
one because right now you can go to Amazon and buy one for $350.
So he's probably going to make that like $1,000 and only have one brand.
The core,
the Chinese are just going to sell them anyway for,
Ooh fuck.
You just gotta keep looking at selling them.
You can stop them.
I mean they,
they fucking copy towns.
They copying tire towns.
They copy everything over there.
It's okay.
It's kind of,
I kind of liked that,
do it.
You know,
I don't like the fact that someone's counterfeiting someone's work,
but I love the fact that we live in a world,
it's so crazy that there's a part of the world where you just accept that
they're just going to copy everything.
They have a whole fake apple store and China total fake apple store.
You go in there as the apple logo.
All the shit is counterfeit and you never seen it before.
It's crazy.
It's fucking amazing.
I mean,
look,
if I was apple,
I'd be pissed.
But you're making plenty of money.
You should be laughing.
You should be laughing at the fact that this exists.
I mean,
if it sucks,
if you're in China and you want it,
oh look,
I'll just go to the apple store and get my,
how come it doesn't have what?
Why does it have a USB board and the bottom of the iPhone?
Like what is like,
they just make their own shit.
Just slap an apple logo on it.
Yeah.
They don't give a fuck man.
They copy entire cities.
There's an exact replica of Paris in China down to every street.
Yeah.
They have an Eiffel tower.
They've got no originality there.
Nothing.
No one's looking at their city and going,
let's uh,
it's be unique here.
I don't know,
you got a wonder.
I mean I'm not a sociologist.
You've got to wonder like what is it about certain cultures that promotes
creativity?
Like obviously America,
like America is known for being a very creative part of the country.
And if you look at like African Americans,
African Americans are known as being like some of the most creative and
innovative people as far as like co culture as far as like the way they dress
and the way they talk.
They like the most imitated,
you know,
like they're like,
they're,
they're pushing music.
Like,
think about like Chuck Berry,
Jimi Hendrix,
you know,
like go back to like the old days of rock and roll,
James Brown,
all these black eyes,
he's white guys were like,
fuck,
we had to do what they're doing.
Like Jimi Hendrix.
Like when they came along,
the Beatles watched him and they're like,
we got to fucking quit music.
Like,
what are we doing?
Like this fucking,
what is this guy doing?
Everybody was like,
Jesus Christ.
And what is it that makes them like that?
You know,
what is it that makes America like a hub of innovation?
There's some innovative places in the world,
but this spot,
especially when it comes to art,
like when it comes to standup comedy,
well,
we do,
yeah.
Why?
Why are,
why go to Germany or Australia that,
uh,
no one's pumping out movies.
TV shows like,
uh,
like America does a little bit and they,
they produce like,
look,
good cop.
Like Jim Jefferies came from Australia.
He's a great comic.
They've got some really funny guys over there.
Um,
there's some real good logo comics and they make some good movies and stuff like
that.
But there's not that many people in Australia.
Australia is a giant place and it's got as many people as la.
Yeah,
I,
I'm not,
I'm,
I was just saying in regards to entertainment,
yeah.
As a whole,
America seems to have that kind of unlocked down.
We've got it on fleek.
Yeah.
I don't know,
man.
It's weird.
Like Germany not good at all.
Like Germany's real stiff to Brian.
Were you around when that guy was coming to the store?
Were you around when that guy was coming to stores?
All guy from Germany with the hair?
What's his name?
Oh,
no,
I don't know if Marie boss,
no.
He was a really,
really popular guy in Germany and he had decided that he was going to make it in
America and I mean,
he barely spoke English.
God,
yeah.
I came with a z doing juggling.
He was,
had a suit on.
Uh,
I forget his name.
I forget his name too,
but we were all like,
what?
Like,
what is this guy doing?
Like it was interesting because we kind of like respected the fact this guy had
the balls.
He realized that like for Standup Comedians,
like when I was living in Boston,
we would all hear about the comedy store.
It was like Mecca.
It was always spoken about in hush tones.
Like you got to go to the comedy store.
That's where prior started out.
That's where Ken is in,
started out and everybody was like,
Oh,
the comedy store with the comedy store.
And then you know,
you get there and you'd see fucking James Stevens,
the third asking for a standing ovation.
You're like,
what the fuck is going on here?
Like singing wizard of Oz songs and shit.
Like it was a dark time in the nineties it was like we had missed the Kinison
wave and you know when you and I were first starting at the store,
I was a few years before you,
I was,
I started in 94 I'm at the store and it was just like,
Whoa,
this place is dark.
Like it was gross.
It was like a lot of lot of bad comedy going on their bed.
But this fucking dude decided,
hey,
you know,
I'm a big star in Germany but I'm going to come to America.
I'm going to try to make it,
didn't even speak English.
Frank Lumberman.
That's his,
that's his name.
Frank Lumberman.
Yeah.
Nice guy.
Real Nice Guy.
Just didn't work.
He just,
his comedy was like slap sticky like Charlie Chaplin movie type Shit.
Like you would fall down and fucking,
he didn't know what was going on.
I went on stage and it was like,
he was like the,
I think you had a talk show in Germany and came here and he tried to make it
work and it's amazing how many people come in and out of that comedy stuff.
You,
if you went back and looked at the people that came in and they stayed for a
little bit,
they left and so it was,
yeah,
the names on the walls.
Sometimes I'll just sit there with Google open and just Google people's names on
the walls.
Have them.
I can't even find on Google,
like there's like some guy named Mc Ren or something like or mc Zen and he's
like,
well that's a weird name for a comic.
So nothing about him.
There's some towing truck company on the side of the law.
Have you ever looked at the wall?
There's like a lot of names.
I think people just put up there without them knowing.
It's like with doctors,
they're like,
there's like doctors,
like whatever happened to Mike,
the ophthalmologist.
Ah,
I'm just not doing it anymore.
You know?
Like does that happen?
Like they go to the ophthalmologist conventions and just quit.
He just quit.
Like probably not as much.
Right.
They get saddled with all these bills and you know,
there's no student loans for comedians.
I don't think.
I've never seen a guy or met a guy that used to,
used to do a medical stuff.
I ran into a guy at the improv there the night that was an open mic or when I
was an open miker and from Boston and he just decided,
he goes,
yeah,
I haven't done comedy at all.
I haven't been on stage 16 years,
but I thought about it all the time.
I decided to come back.
Wow.
What,
you know,
how do I get spots?
Like he's fucking ran away with that.
We can't even,
this is a conversation,
how do I speak English?
Where you gotta start with the alphabet?
Fuck man.
Like look,
look,
even say to a guy like that,
go go to kill Tony.
Yeah.
He's got an advantage over someone who hasn't done it at all.
And there are people that start deep in their forties me,
there's no age limit.
No,
you could be a great comic.
You could start when you're 50 and become a great comic.
You just have to be willing to put in that time.
You have to have that energy.
Yeah.
Mean it's going to take some time.
I mean like when do you think you guys started feeling comfortable in your own
skin and and on stage?
Was that something that
I think I might have figured it out for an hour.
I think like there's a time low chain,
I think 10 years in.
Yeah,
I think 10 years or the number.
So you probably started right when I was,
I was 10 years in when you started.
So you started in [inaudible] 98.
I started in [inaudible] 88.
Oh Wow.
So when you saw me,
I was just,
just kind of,
I could really do an hour.
I could really go on the road and I could do an hour and I had a special,
then I had my first,
uh,
comedy set or a Warner brothers CD.
Then I put out and,
uh,
I felt like I could do comedy.
You know,
I felt like it wasn't a fraud anymore,
you know,
but it still didn't,
like if someone was gonna come see me that I liked,
I'd panic.
Ooh.
You know?
Yeah.
Fuck someone famous that you like,
come see you.
Oh No.
Stay home.
Let me go on stage with no pressure.
You know,
it takes fucking forever,
man.
It takes forever.
So he's one of the most brutal grinds and all of Showbiz.
Yeah.
It is a brutal grind.
And,
uh,
you mentioned someone when someone's famous in the crowd,
even when you're in the crowd though,
anywhere at the Er,
we were in the crowd.
Uh,
and I know your laugh,
I know your left and you're laughing at other comedians.
So when I'm on stage,
um,
I'm listening for a Joe Rogan
eight minutes in,
I'm like,
this guy's not live.
I was laughing at you the other day,
but I
listen to certain things in the room.
I mean,
you don't do,
you don't hear like you're trying to make somebody laugh.
There's not people like you hear Joey Diaz laugh.
Yeah,
I remember to this day one of them,
like when I was like,
well,
I'm a fucking comedian.
So when Paul Mooney was laughing,
Paul Mooney when I first started fucking treated me like I was the plague,
you know,
some cute little white boy on some stupid sitcom trying to make it at the comedy
store.
I was a non paid regular.
I mean,
I said hello,
Hello Mr Man.
Woody preterm walked right by me.
Like I was on fire.
I didn't give a fuck.
And then one night I was,
I was doing a set of late at,
and it was like fucking 20 people in the audience.
But,
uh,
I used to do those sets.
Like the place is packed,
you know,
I didn't,
I don't believe in throwing away a set,
you know,
if I'm going to do a set,
I try my best.
And uh,
I heard,
which is Moody's lap.
Oh,
I forget what the bit was.
I really wish I remembered what the bit,
what is it?
Controversial.
Bitter.
I remember that it was a fucked up bit and I came offstage and Mooney fucking
grabbed me by both shoulders and said,
you're a real comic.
You are a real come.
You did that set in front of those 20 people.
Like there was a thousand motherfuckers in that room.
You're a real comic.
And I was like,
wow.
I remember how good that feels.
Like hearing him laugh was like,
wow,
Paul Mooney thinks I'm funny.
Yeah.
It's,
it's nice to hear other comedians laugh at your stuff.
That's,
oh,
it's giant.
It's like you could have 300 strangers laugh,
but you hear a one comedian lamping like I'm in the group.
Yeah.
Diaz was in the back of the comedy store the other night.
Fucking Howlin when he's Howard.
Yeah.
Ah,
you're that fucking bellowing lap and d as is always smacking things,
smack and people and he's laughing.
Smacking tables.
Yeah,
I saw your special,
your sh you showtime specials.
The showtime special.
Yeah,
I was on a,
on the road,
I forget where it was.
Just was flipping through the channels.
I think it was in Vegas actually,
and it was just,
you know,
after show bored watching TV and you,
your,
your special came on and I hadn't seen you do a set because I hadn't been at the
store in like six or seven years.
Just,
you know,
2007 was when I quit.
And,
um,
this was,
you know,
maybe what,
two years ago,
when was your special?
Two years ago.
2012 fucking excellent.
That was really,
really good.
Thank you.
It was tight.
It was funny.
You were comfortable up there and I was like,
God damn,
I haven't seen Sebastian a long time.
You were fucking killing it,
right?
Yeah.
And when you tweeted at me and the message of it's like,
wow,
that's,
that's nice.
Because I always thought at the comedy store when you were there,
I,
I don't know.
I for some reason I don't think you got what I was doing.
I don't blame you.
What the Nymph wasn't sure.
Well,
we were always friendly.
I know we were always friendly,
but for whatever the reason we weren't like,
uh,
whenever like hanging out there,
I was kind of in my own little world.
And in your own little world with everybody though,
you kind of would go there and do your shit and then get out of it.
Yeah,
I was kind of,
I never really hung out.
I did,
but I didn't end there was like you had that little cluster of people in the
back there,
which I never kind of got into that little circle.
It's just one of these guys.
I've always been the Guy Kinda on the outskirts,
even in school and whatever.
I was always kind of the quiet kid that,
you know,
the shirts,
shirts,
open nipples,
nipples,
shirts.
Yeah,
no,
I was always kind of on the outskirts.
So anyway,
that's a fast forward when you said that you really enjoy what I was doing.
I was like,
wow,
that's,
that's a nice car.
Yeah.
I sent out,
there was a tweet I put out run like a few years ago.
Like right after I saw it I put out.
But yeah,
when I saw you at the comedy store the other night too,
I was noticing,
I was like,
he's so comfortable on stage now.
Like you're so you're so like,
uh,
in your own,
your own rhythm,
you know,
which is like one of the harder things for comedian to find,
like find your own rhythm.
Like you could say the same stuff year after year after year and just not good.
And then one day you figure out how to do it.
You figure out how it gels in people's minds and then,
yeah,
that's it.
Yeah,
you're right.
It's just,
it's,
it's a dance up there.
And I think that you were doing about it,
kid,
about the kid that you just really didn't like.
I don't want to,
I want to give away the bit.
Okay.
Was it the getting slapped in the back of the neck?
The thing about that you,
you ran into a kid at a party and you're like,
I'm just not into this kid
is great cause it was like
the,
it's one of those co it was like,
I don't want to give it away,
but it's one of those bits where it's dependent upon your rhythm and everyone
understanding how you look at things,
you know?
Yeah.
It's not real.
It's a combination of things.
I mean you got people that writing beautiful jokes and this and that.
And the other thing,
I really admire those people,
but the way I work is it's more of like a way you say something or the timing or
a pause or a look and it,
it Kinda all gels together for some reason.
And,
uh,
and that's what I noticed that people were kind of gravitating towards watching
my act was all this kind of physical and all this kind of like kind of weird
faces that,
uh,
you know,
some other people might look at like this.
It's funny that the kind of stolen all these faces or whatnot,
but I don't know,
I've always been in a very expressive family.
So when we sat around the table,
which seemed to be kind of my first stage growing up in this Italian household
and everybody was kind of telling stories and we all kind of just,
it was,
everybody was kind of funny and we never really got serious.
Cause if we got serious,
we would start to cry.
Very emotional family who's either,
we were laughing or crying.
It was no in between.
That's Italian is Italian.
So,
uh,
yeah.
And,
and it took a while to kind of find that rhythm.
Yeah.
It's an interesting thing,
isn't it?
Everybody's got their own rhythm and you,
you really,
you can't,
we can't predict it.
Like I always use Mitch Hedberg as an example.
Like,
if you,
if you ever saw Hedberg live,
like Hedberg would say things that on paper we're not funny at all.
What you would be howling.
Like he had that bit about the doubletree,
like naming the doubletree in like how,
how did they name that?
You know,
how about three trees?
No.
Doubletree.
Yes,
the meeting adjourned.
I'm not doing the bit justice,
but like he had a bunch of bits like that.
Like would you like,
would you like a frozen banana?
No,
but I like a regular banana later.
So yes,
it's so ridiculous.
But if you saw that on paper you would go,
that's not really funny.
But then you go see him live and you're dying.
To this day if bored and I'm in my car,
I have a playlist on my,
uh,
my iPhone where I have some standup on it and I'll go to that Hedburg CD.
To this day,
you know,
I've heard it all a hundred times.
It's squeaky clean,
squeaky clean and fucking killer.
But this is like,
he found his style.
He found his rhythm,
you know,
you got to find whatever it is and no one can tell you,
that's why comedy classes or just kind of ridiculous shit.
Joe,
I took a comedy class.
Well,
it's good to get you on stage.
Who taught it?
I took a car,
this is my,
uh,
another introduction until Los Angeles never did comedy before,
but once,
so I go,
how am I going to get in to the comedy store?
I heard the comedy store was the place to be.
So I looked through the,
whatever the trades.
Sandy shore,
who's Mitzi shores,
daughter has a thing called sandy shores sandbox comedy class.
So I'm thinking,
perfect.
I take her class.
If she likes me,
she tells the mother I'm in sort of stay sandy shores,
like,
uh,
just so you know,
I don't really get along with my mother.
We're not really talking right now.
And I'm like,
yeah,
that's $400 down the drain.
But uh,
for me,
I enjoyed the comedy class because it gave me an opportunity to go up once a
week in front of a supportive environment.
Say what you will about that,
you know,
I mean the people that are there and support,
oh that was good.
You know,
not going out into the wolves.
But for me it was like a way to kind of just get my legs a little bit.
So I took it for for six months and it kind of helped me get off the ground a
little bit because I didn't know,
I didn't know what to do.
Nothing wrong with that.
I mean that's a great way to start really.
You know,
it's just no one could teach you how to do comps.
Oh No,
I've got to kind of figure out how to do it on your own.
Like I've seen comedy classes where they,
you know,
they give people bad advice,
dealt with a talent.
Somebody like,
you know,
worst is like club owners.
Like Jamie Masada told my friend Todd wants,
you have to be generation x guy,
you and a Janet,
Aisha,
next guy.
When you go on stage,
what you going to do is only talk about generation x,
my generation,
generation x,
we think this and you do the and,
and the kid was like,
fuck,
do I have to do this?
Like if I don't do this,
this guy's not gonna let me get on stage.
Like the worst fucking possible advice.
You know,
like who's going to make it with the generation x guy fucking how long is that
going to lie?
Yeah.
He told Tony that he,
he's like,
Tony,
you need to wear a cowboy hat.
Do you wear a cowboy hat?
You look like woody from toy story.
Fuck Shit.
Again,
Guy owns a comedy club.
Yeah.
And when you find out that he's the guy that introduced Michael Jackson,
it was kids he molested allegedly.
Oh yeah.
Cause he used to,
he used to work with all those like dying kids.
Yeah.
Unfortunately it's the in between guy.
Here's the fucking,
this is Corey Feldman.
Tight ties.
Hello.
I don't think he said that.
I don't think you get introduced into Corey Feldman.
Anita.
Corey Feldman wasn't dying of a disease as far as I know.
I'm sure.
Hmm.
Um,
but now you're,
you're fucking Torin.
You're doing the road,
you're killing it everywhere.
I see.
Everywhere,
everywhere I'm at.
Improv's all that shit.
You're doing great.
Yeah.
Knock on wood.
It's been good.
Kind of getting myself involved with the clubs.
And did you start out at the store?
You started out in la or out in Los Angeles?
1998 I did comedy at my college.
I went to Northern Illinois University in Dekalb and they had like a comedy
contest where you auditioned in front of like the student council and then I got
to open up for the national headline and comedian.
Who was that?
Reese.
Uh,
what's his name?
His last name was Reese.
Forgot.
He used to do this thing with the used to go up on stage and goal
or,
I dunno,
it was like a
growl.
I don't know.
That was his like moniker.
So,
uh,
yeah,
he was the guy.
So I go on stage just as in like,
you know,
like a college,
400 cedar or it's like a free show for the students,
primarily a black crowd.
I go on stage and I start to do my act and I'm starting to hear sad man.
I didn't know what the Hell Sandman was at the time,
but I found out later at showtime at the Apollo,
that's what they call when they want the guy to come out with the hook,
the sand.
Oh,
oh
no.
But I'm like,
I'm going through this.
It's gone.
He said,
what is,
is there another guy coming out?
What does Sandman,
so it was bad.
It was a bad experience,
but I knew,
I just knew I had an ability to make people have maybe not yet on stage.
It was primarily based on my family.
If I was making my family laugh,
particularly my mother,
if she was laughing,
I knew that I had some ability to make people laugh.
It was just kind of trying to find it on stage.
It's a weird fucking journey,
you know?
It's a very weird journey.
The journey of trying to figure out what it is and how to do it,
which way to go,
you know,
and you can go the wrong way for a long time.
Then you have to bring it back.
You know,
like there's guys that create characters like emo Phillips,
you know,
he,
he have this character,
you're what do on,
which is great until you're 60 which he is now.
He's like an old dude and now he can't do that character anymore.
So you go to see emo Phillips if like you were a fan of his and the eighties and
they're like,
yeah,
we're going to go see email and you see him now and you're like,
um,
what's going on?
Like he's just talking like he's not doing the character thing.
Like I'm surprised it's still works on dice because it,
it doesn't seem like it should,
but it does.
Cogs,
it's universal.
It's still work that will last forever.
That will last forever.
You know why?
Because he has become that guy.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
He's the guy.
He's that guy.
He does it.
You know,
if anybody saw him in the early days when he was Andrew Silverstein,
the dice character was one of the guys that he would do in his act.
He had a bunch of characters.
He would do John Travolta.
He does an incredible John Travolta impression.
He would do all these things.
He would sing,
he would have all these different like pieces of his act and then he would do
the dice man and the dice man was based apparently on the nutty professor with
Jerry Lewis like Jerry Lewis would become,
he was like this nutty professor and they would become this really fucking cool
guy who had smoked cigarettes and the chicks all fawned over him.
So he became like that guy.
But now there's the blurred line between who he was.
Like Andrew Silverstein and then the dice man.
He's not gone.
He is the dice man.
Now you run into him at fucking Ralph's.
He's got weightlifting gloves on.
He's got he's,
he taught me how to get this fanny pack.
I did not know.
This is the roots.
Fanny pack is the one,
I sell them a higher primate.com.
I fucked.
We found out about this from dice.
Dice a recommendation.
That's right.
He came in with it.
He came here that with sweat pants,
with this fucking beautiful,
glorious fanny pack.
And I go,
where did you get that?
He goes,
that's nice,
right?
I'm like,
that's fucking gorgeous.
I test the greatest fanny pack I've ever seen.
He goes,
oh,
it's the best stuff,
best one.
And he's like,
show me all the features.
Look,
this one's got a little buckled,
just got a zipper.
I'm like,
Whoa,
it is the best.
But he's that guy now that really is who he is.
He's like all the time,
24 hours.
You call them up in the middle of the night.
He's dice man.
He became that guy.
Yeah,
we,
uh,
I opened up for him for like two,
three years.
He really,
uh,
he picked me out of the comedy story.
He came up to me and uh,
at first he goes,
um,
you know what you should do.
I said,
what?
When you go on stage,
put a shock
pants and then you'll be like the comedian who's just got a big cock
and this is like,
this is like my guy I looked up to
and he's telling me.
And then I actually,
I went home that night,
gone.
Should I do,
should I be CACTI?
So,
uh,
anyway,
we go.
It was this kind of beard,
little friendship.
And he asked me if I wanted to go to Las Vegas with him at the Stardust hotel.
And I'm like,
yeah,
call my parents.
I go,
I'm opening up for dice clay at the stone us.
My mom was like,
yeah,
you made it,
you made it.
Wow.
So they all came out to see you
hung out with them on the road.
And uh,
the first time we played Vegas,
I'm like,
I can't believe I'm here and Wayne Newton theater.
I wonder what we're going to do,
you know,
excited and we'll go,
probably go out and dinner and we'll go out to a club,
hang by the pool,
probably got a Cabana,
and he goes,
we'll go and grow.
Uh,
we'll go on the furniture shopping today.
I go,
Huh.
And Los Vegas.
So we went furniture shopping because he had a house out there and he was
furnishing his house.
So we would go to furniture stores and he would tell me,
sit on the couch and sit.
When he think I don't say grand guy,
it's better than anything.
I got it at my house,
it's fantastic.
And we would go to eat.
I mean,
this was a process.
We were laying on carpets to see if the carpet was comfortable.
And uh,
I'm like,
uh,
okay.
I guess this is what you,
you do.
This is my first time on the road and were furniture shop out.
Let's go out.
And I made it a casino.
Maybe we go for dinner.
And he's like,
are you kidding me?
It's like the Beatles.
If I go out,
that's like the Beethoven,
it's like mania.
People gonna lose their mind.
I can look,
let's try it.
And sure enough,
we went through the casino yet is the glasses.
He had like some big glitter ball on his back of his jacket that we went
through.
And it was like,
it was fantastic.
It was like,
Oh wow,
this is what he's talking about.
So to swarm him,
right.
Just warm them.
He's got like a,
like a loyal fan base.
Oh yeah.
It's crazy.
I went to see him,
me and Jimmy Norton and Brian and uh,
who else?
Anthony [inaudible] from opening Anthony and Bobby Kelly and uh,
we all went to a Anthony and um,
and Jimmy Norton worn town for the fights.
And I have the night off.
We had the nine off,
so we found out dice was in town.
So a fuck,
let's go see dice.
Let's go see dice at the Riviera.
So like,
which is classic Old Vegas,
you know,
that was the first place I ever worked in Vegas.
So we went there,
we went to the,
uh,
you know,
they have the upper a showroom like the bigger show room where they have these,
to have that,
the drag queen show,
you know,
the Frank Marino and you should do the drag queen show,
this famous drag queen show.
So we went up there,
we had a fucking great time.
We had a great time.
It was really fun.
It was fun to sit there and the audience and just how,
just how all laughing and his set was great.
It was really funny.
We had a good time and then he was like all happy to see us.
We went backstage,
we're hanging out with him and it was cool.
It was really cool.
His son does drums,
sunflowers,
man.
I want to go see their band about four months ago here in the valley and a great
band.
And he taught me a lot.
I mean he was,
we'd have like long discussions at night cause he didn't really sleep and then
we'd come,
come by,
let's talk and he doesn't sleep well.
You know what was up a lot,
you know,
I don't know for,
for a comedian.
I go to bed early and he was up.
What time you go to bed?
Um,
I don't know.
1130 kids,
right?
No,
not yet.
Yeah.
Newly married.
37 30.
I'm going to be weird.
I don't come to anything.
I don't think,
I don't
get anything done until my kids are asleep.
Like I,
I try it like either I can only write when they're at school or when they're
asleep.
That's the only time I can get things done because otherwise it's like,
daddy come and do this dad and want to do that.
Daddy,
come do this.
What do you think of this?
It's like,
so I don't even try it.
Like during the day when I'm with her,
I'm,
it's just play time with the kids or hanging out or do we do art together?
We do a lot of drawing together,
but at nighttime that's when I get my shit done.
So from 9:00 PM on,
that's,
if I'm not,
if I don't have a set from 9:00 PM on,
I'm writing,
that's when I do my writing.
That's what I do.
I watch documentaries,
you know,
all that shit.
Yeah.
I get it all done at night.
So oftentimes I don't go to bed until three,
four o'clock.
Oh yeah,
no,
you're late.
It's pretty normal for me.
Four or five or five.
But he's,
he's like comedy story told to and then math and then,
and then it hooks Tinder and Grindr.
But take it as a workout.
So you're all over the men.
Yeah.
So dice would be up like,
you know,
he's,
he's telling me,
no,
you can't look at other people's career or you've got your own path.
That's good advice.
You know,
you can't be upset if somebody else gets something.
You know.
It just,
just really taught me Kinda how to,
he's the only thing you have control of is how you perform and write anything
else is up in the,
that's very good advice because Dan is a lot of wasted energy that a lot of
comedians have worrying about other people's sets and worrying about other
people's careers.
Like why is that guy getting this?
Why is she,
why is she on this fucking show?
How come he got a thing or this and that and nothing to do with it.
We've all seen that though.
Those guys that get poisoned by other people's success and those guys,
they always wind up failing to like,
it falls apart.
Like that's like jealousy is a poison that only it does the opposite of what you
wanted to do instead of like when you,
when you're jealous about somebody else's career,
it doesn't do anything bad to them,
but it does something bad to you.
Like it,
it's,
it poisons you.
Yeah.
It's weird.
Like people that say,
fuck that guy,
he's got this fucking TV show.
He's the only even fucking phone.
You know what I remember when he first started it,
it was fucking middle and he was an open worker.
Like it doesn't matter.
It doesn't matter.
He's on TV now and you're here,
here.
Here's you,
you when that,
when the guy says,
ladies and gentlemen,
please welcome Mike Cost.
Fuck.
And you go on stage,
that's your time,
dude.
That's it.
All that shit in between.
Like you don't,
don't do that.
It's a waste.
It's not good.
So dice gave me some good advice to [inaudible] the reason why I started going
on the road.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I was,
I was doing just a store.
I would just do the store.
And then somewhere in the 90s when I was on news radio,
dice goes,
you're a funny guy.
You should do it all wrong.
And I go,
yeah.
He goes,
yeah,
she's doing the road.
Why don't you do the road?
And I go,
I don't know.
I mean,
I'm always working here.
He goes,
yeah,
but you know what?
He goes,
you've got TV shows.
you're on TV.
He board.
If that goes away,
it goes,
you don't want to fucking need those guys.
He goes,
you know,
you could do great.
You could have a great career on the road.
And I remember thinking like,
he's fucking right.
Like what if TV shows go away?
Yeah.
Like what if you know,
news radio gets canceled and then I can't get another show and then I'm fucked.
I should go through the road.
And I started doing the road because the dice,
Tonya percent,
100% his advice now this,
did you fall into news radio and like,
Hey,
did you get a lot of addition for that part and get it for it?
Yeah,
that was totally a,
you were just doing the audition game.
You booked a show and then,
well,
I had a show that it was a show that got canceled.
It was called hardball.
That was on in 94 93 or 94 and it didn't last.
It only went like six episodes.
I came out for that,
but when it,
when I was an idiot,
you know,
25 or something,
whatever the fuck I was 26 and I thought,
oh,
this is definitely going to go,
I'm going to get an apartment.
So I leased an apartment and then I'm stuck here.
Once the show got canceled after six episodes,
I was like,
oh great.
And I'm stuck here and I didn't know what to do and I was trying to figure it
out.
And uh,
I said,
well,
I guess I'll just stay for awhile.
I hate,
I was ready to go back to New York.
I hated it out here.
I hated working with actors,
like I couldn't believe how pretentious they were and ridiculous and pampered.
Like working with actors was fucking mind boggling to me because I was used to
comics who,
you know,
especially like east coast comics constantly busting each other's balls,
always joking around and there was like a comradery with comics.
Like we would go on the road together,
like comics would give each other the taglines.
We'd always say,
hey,
it was great.
Said you know this and that and blah blah blah.
And you know,
he would,
there was like a feeling of like belonging and then all of a sudden I was out
here with these actresses like,
Oh God,
I can't even,
I can't even talk to these fucking people.
They were all back stabby and they were like,
they were,
they would fuck with you before you're seen and say creepy shit to you.
And there was like,
there was so much weirdness.
It was just so much weirdness had fakeness.
They would say things that,
you know,
they didn't really mean.
They would love to say like,
they meet people,
they had this fake way of talking like,
Oh,
nice to see you.
Like it was like,
there's like this fucking,
they would pretend to be this person who's like super professional so that they
could get hired and do something else.
Meanwhile,
they were a boiling cauldron of crazy under the surface,
just trying to keep it together until they fucking gotten to their car and just
scream all the way home and then pop pills or do whatever the fuck they did.
So I,
um,
I got another development deal I did from the hardball show.
I got a development deal with NBC and I was supposed to do my own show and then
they,
uh,
brought me in and they said,
we would like to talk to you about something.
We've got this other show that a,
we're going to cast.
We're,
we're um,
replacing one of the characters.
The original character was Ray Romano,
is that right?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Ray Romano was originally in the pilot and then he got fired from the pilot and
they brought in a new guy to play the Ray Romano character in the pilot.
And then they got rid of that guy.
And so I felt better cause I didn't replace ray or a place,
the Guy who replaced ray and then um,
they had auditions and I came in and auditioned for it.
Wow.
Yeah,
it's amazing how stuff that's stupid.
Dumb luck.
Just dumb luck.
I remember being at the audition,
the first one was a cattle call.
I was like fucking a hundred dudes.
And I was like,
what are the odds of getting that Jesus Christ?
What are these fucking people?
I did the audition and it was not funny at all,
but they did it on purpose.
They literally wrote a script that wasn't funny cause they wanted to make sure
people weren't like fucking hamming it up.
You want to make sure that people didn't try super hard and make something
funny.
So,
uh,
then I got a call back and I was like,
really?
It was like,
okay.
So I went in for the call back and this time the script was hilarious and I was
like,
oh,
I see what they did.
They weeded out all the Hams,
they weeded out all the,
the Huc and I went to the script and it was mean,
and two or three other guys that looked like they were about to go to nom,
they were pale and sweaty and nervous and going over their lines.
And I remember looking at these guys,
I'm like,
oh,
I got this.
So I plopped down on the couch where these guys were going over the lines.
I put my fucking feet up,
I put my hands behind my head and I was like,
look,
hey,
you fucking pussies.
You guys are scared.
And because he's very scared.
I knew these are the only guys that were auditioning.
I was super confident.
So I went in there like super relaxed and I nailed it and then I got it.
But there was just looking at those guys,
looking at people that are scared can give you a lot of,
yeah,
yeah.
Especially if you hear it from the waiting room or somebody else's audition,
you're like,
I ain't even funny guys.
I got a funny in there.
Yeah,
it was.
They were,
they were like,
they were just calm.
They were,
they were actors rather.
They weren't comics.
They didn't know how to end.
The writing was really good,
so I went from the show that was like the worst case show.
It was terrible show that horrible show.
It just wasn't good.
They brought in this really bad guy who was like an executive producer of coach.
Remember that show coach and he was like hammered it out.
Everything was just gross,
shitty writing,
real hacky premises are just garbage show.
And then from that to working with Phil Hartman and Dave Foley and Steven Rude,
I was like,
Jesus Christ,
Maura Tierney,
candy Alexander and Vicky Lewis.
I was like,
this is nuts.
Just sitting at the fucking table with Phil Hartman,
like reading with Phil Hartman.
Like I'd only been doing standup for five years and all of a sudden I'm sitting
next to Phil Hartman at this,
this table.
Crazy reading for a sitcom.
Like this is madness.
This doesn't even make sense.
Yeah.
Just dumb luck.
But you know what?
All that stuff was cool but it was bigger to me was becoming a paid regular at
the comedy store.
Yeah.
That was the biggest thing to me.
It was like having a sitcom that's all well and good.
But when I became a paid regular at the store,
I was like,
Holy Shit.
I remember going back to my apartment.
I had an apartment,
the oakwoods and all those uh,
those little shitty pre uh,
pre fucking furnished apartments.
I used to go back to that shit hole every night after I was a non paid regular,
these depressing farted in couches and Burbank.
Yeah.
You know that off of olive oil,
I used to live.
Corey Haim died there
at the Auto Co.
Quick ones.
Really make sense doing drugs.
Yeah.
Wow.
All right,
well I got there first,
got there before he died,
but once I became a paid regular the store,
that was everything to me that uh,
you know,
I was in,
I was like,
you know,
you have like these little milestones.
I be like,
yeah,
you know,
like getting a record with Warner brothers.
That was a milestone.
You know,
you're like,
if there's little things where you're like,
okay,
I can't get care,
I guess I'm doing this.
I am actually doing this because for a while you feel like a fraud and now for
the first few years of your career you're out there doing your,
you know,
you just feel like a fraud and people want you to feel like a fraud to other
comics want you to feel like a fraud.
Like there's a lot of,
a lot of fucking crabs in a bucket going on in that business.
Especially in early,
a lot of crabs in a bucket.
They just try to pull the other crabs down as they tried to get out.
Yeah.
That's why I kinda,
I just stayed,
I had a job working at the four season,
so towel while I was doing the standup.
So I had kind of like a separate group of friends at my job.
I didn't really hang out with a lot of comedians at night just because I was so
involved at this four seasons during the day and I was,
I was hanging out with them after work and I one season down here?
Yeah.
Which where's that though?
Heaney and Burton way.
What'd you do over there?
I was in the windows loan.
I was a cocktail waitress,
basically put about 10 girls and me and another guy.
Did you put the sock in?
Of course.
This fucking guy.
Oh yeah.
So how long did you do that for?
Seven and a half years.
Started in 98 and then I left in 2005 wow.
I mean that's supplemented my income.
That's was,
I wasn't in the road guy,
didn't really do a lot of feature work.
I just kind of honed it in here in Los Angeles and,
and worked at the four seasons.
In the meantime,
just kind of hoping something would break.
Just doing the comedy store and just local local sets.
That's awesome.
So where else did you besides the store?
Uh,
well I went to,
I went to the laugh factory and Massada asked me what lay lay you angry?
Well he's like,
Hey,
hey Sam.
Kennison angry for a reason.
But yeah.
So why was Sam Kinison angry for a reason?
I don't know.
He said he had a reason to.
His anger and my anger was displaced.
So mad at Ross dress for less because I remember that bed keep fucking so angry.
That was my first introduction of the La.
I went to Ross dress for less with my father to buy like bedding.
He came out here to visit and he goes,
let's go to Ross.
Thank you.
Get some pillows.
And we walked in.
We're like,
what the F is going on here?
So a bit,
cause it is true,
anybody who's ever been there,
but if the bit they used to do the way he would do it,
like do people just take this and just get across the room?
So we're coming from the northwest suburbs of Chicago,
you know,
very neatly put together stores.
And now I went to the Ross on third and uh,
forget it.
I
mean,
there was just,
it's like a hodge podge of stuff over there.
There's like a bra mixed in with like a games.
So it was like,
that's where that anger came from,
of like,
God,
I feel like a fish out of water.
That's the whole thing.
When I first came to La,
I didn't feel like I fit in.
I feel like I was,
you know,
I was the guy wearing the caviar reach,
he's going to a nightclub.
It's 17 years old.
So we'll take the cues that everybody feels like they don't fit in.
You know,
everybody does in the beginning you can pretend,
but you never,
I mean,
I feel like I fit in now.
Oh yeah.
You know,
it's a long time.
Yeah,
it takes awhile.
But in the beginning I think everybody feels like they don't fit in.
I think one of the great things is what you're doing.
The,
uh,
um,
killed Tony that gives people an introduction to stand up and an introduction to
like,
you know,
like you're in the big leagues.
Like real,
real quick.
Like you're on a podcast that gets seen by or listened to by hundreds of
thousands of people and you're there with dom.
I rare a judging you and Tony Hinchcliffe and Sarah Silverman and all these
different people that are really funny comedians or up like watching you do
stand up putting you in these very super high pressure situations.
You're doing one minute in front of a microphone and then you kind of get to say
hi to those people.
They become,
they've seem like normal.
I wish
I had it when I was a kid or when I started off because all right,
you,
that's so good for them because they can have it on tape.
They can go over it.
They can have like professional comedians like dissect what they're doing wrong
instead of just like doing it in front of two other comics that even pay
attention and you just go home,
go,
oh,
I think I did it.
Okay.
Those are the open Mike Nights where you're doing it.
You're doing your act to a bunch of people of senior act and their comics.
Yeah.
You'll like 10 people in the audience are all comics.
Those are brutal.
It's almost like half the shows are that,
you know,
you're an open mic or I,
I mean when I started it was Chris Delea,
Dean Delray me and we'd go to the same four different open mics every day and it
was just like,
oh,
you're my audience last,
you know,
our,
it's the same audience over and over because it's just an audience of five other
comics that you went from one to open my to another.
Yeah.
That's where some comics,
they fall into that trap of doing stand up for the back of the room.
They'd be like really obscure shit that only the comics think is funny.
Yeah.
I mean it Kinda,
it's Kinda practice in a way,
you know,
it gives you a way to figure out a way to make something funny out of this
moment,
but it's not a real crowd,
you know?
It's just you kind of like fucking around.
It's easy to fall into that and never get out of that too.
For a while I just had to make myself stop.
Like I'm done with this.
I'm not going to hog cafe anymore and spending $5 to go home to five minutes and
I'm like,
they can take charge you.
Yeah.
A lot of places charge you a ha ha used to be $5 but you got a beer and you got
to do five minutes and now it's,
you don't get a beer
for $5 I guess.
Well those clubs are barely hanging on,
you know?
You mean even the ice house,
which is like one of the best clubs in the world.
It kind of barely hanging on,
you know?
Yeah.
Well you got two phones over there for you.
Fuck,
I got the new Samsung note five.
Oh is it by the way,
one of the first phones that I've ever had that almost,
I'm almost done with the iPhone after this phone real.
It's got one of the most amazing cameras.
It's got all these really cool things.
Look at this like if you're,
if you're out and you're just like,
oh,
I need to write a note,
you just take the pin out.
It can be like,
oh,
you could just write it right here on the screen on the screen,
and then you can just be like,
hey,
you know,
I got to remember to eat this.
That,
that's always a problem.
Yeah,
it's crazy good.
I highly recommend this and it's got a feature in the camera where you can just
broadcast right to youtube.
So kind of like periscope.
Uh,
you could just be like,
boom,
I'm broadcasting now on youtube.
Yeah,
it's built into the camera.
they've taken,
they've noticed how a popular periscopes been in live apps like that.
So they've decided just to build it right into the operating system.
So now you can just broadcast live from it.
Why is it better than the edge?
A way better than than the edge.
This,
this is,
I love this.
What's better?
What's better about it?
The problem I had with the edges that the,
that while the edge was neat to look at the,
the corners where it's wrapped around the side,
I was constantly hitting buttons and also had a really sharp edge to it.
You know,
the feel of it,
which just doesn't,
this is more like an iPhone,
so it's,
it's nice and soft.
Sorry.
Yeah.
You can't beat the camera in the Samsungs smaller than an iPhone.
It is smaller than an iPhone.
It's thinner than an iPhone.
Ooh.
It's a good size for you,
man.
My hands are pretty big,
but I could get,
I can get this,
I could do like a one hand to text with those easy.
Yeah,
it's great.
This is awesome.
It also has the ability to edit PDFs.
So if somebody sends you a pdf and was like,
hey,
I need you to print this out and sign it now you can just edit it right on the
fly,
send it back.
Which is cool.
Uh,
the,
I'm just amazed by the camera the most though.
It was the first time that Samsung or any galaxy phone,
it actually had a camera that's I think better than the iPhone camera.
Y'All.
Yeah.
What are you using for your,
um,
for your,
uh,
for your provider,
a t mobile,
and you liked that?
I left him.
Oh,
well,
I'm on a family plan.
Both of these phones.
Uh,
I have unlimited data.
I think it's like $99 a month for both phones.
Unlimited data.
I'm looking through your Instagram.
It's hilarious.
Where you fall.
Brian follows.
All girls are sticking their asses out.
It's just a slew of girls sticking their asses out.
It's one after the other.
All these different scans.
I say stacks.
Skanks with all due respect,
we're all due respect.
A bunch of holes,
a bunch of uz.
Wow.
You've got a lot of hot girls.
You're following my friend.
Oh yeah.
He was single.
I didn't know.
Not Anymore.
Okay.
Got Himself a girl.
Well,
he's not married.
Not married though.
That's the way to go.
Even if you're not single,
you're not married.
And that's the thing about this fucking,
this lady that's not marrying these gay people.
[inaudible] she's doing them a favor,
like,
don't do it.
What are you doing?
You got to got it made you fucks.
You got it made.
It's,
it's right now it's illegal.
Well now,
now it is illegal.
But for the longest time it was illegal and these guys had to go in there and
fuck it up.
I can understand lesbians wanting to get married.
It's every girl's dream.
But come on.
These guys that are fighting for it,
like it's too hard.
Just say you can't do it.
I go out,
it's like a marathon.
I can't do,
I can't run it.
Just say it.
Say you don't have to do it.
Just do it.
Root style,
lay of broom and the ground jump over it like,
like Kizzy and uh,
couldn't to Kente did Joe,
another cool thing about it,
say like if there's an interview of you and you're like,
you know what?
I want to save this interview.
It's on a website right now or something like that.
Oh yeah.
You circle it used to be,
it could take a screenshot or something that this new thing called screen
capture.
Where what,
what,
what you do is screen.
Right.
And so what it does is it takes a picture of it,
then you can go advanced it so it will scroll down automatically,
take a picture,
take a picture.
So go through the whole entire website and now it just made it a huge jpeg.
So you could have like a whole jpeg saved your gallery so it saves a websites
and then you could like ride on it and send it to people if you wanted it to.
Is that how the fat Jewish steals all of us stuff?
Yeah,
that's right.
As soon as you took the pen out,
it kind of lost me because,
uh,
it,
it just seems like a annoying,
well that's a lot going on man.
There's a lot going on.
I mean that you're doing pens.
Honestly,
I never even,
I always forget that,
that there is a pin.
I owe it.
I never take it out.
No,
the new one just clicks in there so you don't,
you don't,
it just snaps in.
So it's like,
isn't there one that's waterproof?
Don't know.
They have a sport.
They have the Samsung s six edge sport or something like that,
which is just a built a little bit more tough and it's waterproof again.
Uh,
I asked about that and he says,
yeah,
it's just a more rugged phone,
but uh,
this is a little bit,
how's the battery life on that thing?
Great.
And it's got the new fast charger.
I have a a charging pad now where I just go home and just set it on this table
and then pick it up.
I said,
I don't have to plug it in anymore.
Do you have to put a special case on it to use that fast charge thing?
Are these,
the new Samsungs are built into the phone and you don't have to take off the
normal case.
So if you have a case on it,
you don't have to take it off.
It just goes through it.
So you just sit down on to conference.
I'm just amazed at the knowledge of like when I listened to the sales guy
telling me the options,
I'm not even there.
I'm just like,
give me the phone,
let me get out of here.
You actually retain the information.
Yeah.
So I love this shit goes on mine and he actually makes videos with these for the
longest time before Amazon fucked him.
And he used to have this great thing he was doing where he would buy something
like buy a camera and then he would review it and then put up a link,
uh,
from his Amazon.
So like if somebody bought it,
he would get like a cut or a kickback.
So I'd get free stuff pretty much.
Cause I would just do such good reviews on these cameras that so many people
would click on it.
It would pay for the camera.
And so it was a way for me to get stuff that like cameras and stuff I couldn't
afford.
Oh,
how come they don't,
why don't,
why isn't that happening anymore?
What happened there?
I Dunno,
they uh,
they said that somebody reported me as saying I had porn on my website and so
they go,
oh well we can't have porn on the website.
And then so they took all,
like they,
I was making like,
I think I'm up to like $7,000 a month in just that Amazon stuff.
And they just took it all away.
Porn on your website?
No,
it's just because it was death squad and like there was like an episode that had
a girl on it that was a porn star and so they'd probably just went there and was
all you need.
Yeah.
Fuck wow.
You want me to can like bank off of that shit.
Yeah.
You ever tried to get back in?
I need to.
I'm on Amazon.
Look it up.
You fucks.
Now.
Didn't apple come up with a bunch of new shit today?
Apple came out with a 12 inch iPad,
which,
so it's called an iPad pro,
which is a,
it's just like a laptop.
I'd like 12 inch laptop without a keyboard.
Uh,
they also came with the iPhone six s which has a better front facing camera now.
It's got a better processor.
It's got the touch three d touch.
What's that called?
Uh,
will reacts when you touch it.
Yeah.
You can feel it.
Um,
they also released a new apple TV,
which is the thing that I am the most interested in because it is now,
it plays games.
It does apps,
and it's the first one to actually,
in the future you're going to have a Joe Rogan app finally.
So when you're opening up your TV,
you're like,
oof.
CNN.
Oh,
Netflix.
Oh Joe Rogan.
So it's going to be like that.
So it's,
so it's going to,
it's the first step into completely destroying the cable industry,
I think.
Okay.
Wow.
Well,
I use apple TV a lot now.
All the time.
I use Netflix on it.
It has HBO go on it.
You can get to those things
which shows like narco or whatever,
that you don't need anything on regular TV anymore.
That alone is just a narco shows.
Great.
Oh,
it's beautiful.
It's like good fellas.
It's so great.
Just I'm halfway in and a,
I'm like,
I'm in,
I mean
anything with drugs,
voiceover guy with a Mustang.
Jamie's see if you could find that article that was on dig yesterday.
It was the narco traffickers on Instagram.
All the shit.
They did.
A bunch of these Mexican narco guys have Instagram pages.
Holy Shit.
Just like they don't give a fuck.
They're just showing all this stuff.
They have their showing gold plated guns,
girls asses.
It's just fucking them shooting guns.
Stacks a money pet tiger like the whole deal.
Like these guys are live in like a Goddamn Scarface move.
They all have scar face pictures.
Like there's this one guy.
Yeah,
that guy's a good guy.
Go to that guy's page.
If you click on that little Instagram thing,
go to his page.
He's got a,
I mean look at it's all booties cars.
Goldlink that gold plated pistol with a BMW.
Yeah.
You scroll down,
you'll see more asses more cars.
Look at that girl's ass.
Jesus.
What an ass fake as fuck.
That's fake is Nancy Reagan's orgasms.
Fuck.
Look at in the ass,
but can't be real.
Right?
I Dunno.
It's graduation ones.
If it is real well,
she's got thick legs.
She might be doing squats a lot.
A lot of booty shots.
Look,
he's got a pet leopard over there to see the lamp.
The pet leopard that God,
go back to the Instagram.
What are you doing?
See the leopard look at that.
Oh,
Jaguar,
leopard.
Whatever the fuck it is.
It's crazy,
bitch.
It's nuts.
Dried.
He wants to eat.
It's fucking,
but these guys are nuts,
man.
They just live in this crazy life to showing all the cool stuff that they have.
Look,
he's got a pet leopard on his bed.
What the fuck,
man?
Dope.
A F dope.
So this is all drug money.
Yeah.
Look at Scarface.
You've got to have a scar face picture.
Yeah.
There's all drug money.
I mean,
there's a bunch of them.
There's quite a few of these.
Got a pet tiger down there.
A pet lion.
There's quite a few of these guys on Instagram that just only have a look at.
This guy is fucking gold plated.
Ak 47 it.
This guy's crazy.
He's got 21,000 followers.
A lot of it's from Instagram.
Look at that guy.
I mean,
a lot of it's from the dig story.
I'll get that girl with the tits pointing the gun at him.
Wow.
That up there
did.
He said,
God damn guns and drugs.
It's only 614 likes.
How rude.
That deserves a lot more likes and is a great picture and either manage to do
with no nipples.
How?
Yeah,
that's perfect.
Big titties.
Those are juicy titties
anymore.
My worst nightmare.
Haha.
Yeah.
There's a bunch of of her and have guns and all kinds of crazy shit,
but these guys are out of their fucking mind.
I mean,
this is the life they're living.
They're living this nutty narco life.
The amount of drug money that's in Mexico right now is,
she's fucking insane.
They're making billions.
Look at that girl's house down at that kind of bottom.
Look at that girl's ass.
Jesus.
Jesus,
his dad's.
What?
A fucking APP.
That can't be real.
That's a fake one.
That's a fake gas,
but whatever.
There's a lot of that lately.
Yeah,
it was in Vegas last week.
I saw a lot of fake asses.
Girls getting carried away.
That's the new thing,
man.
You know,
like they had like giant tits and the 90s were like really popular.
Girls would just get,
tits are way too big.
That's what they're doing now with their houses.
And like they don't match your legs at all.
You have the legs of a lazy girl and the ass of a fucking major league pulled
falter.
Like some grow can jump over the moon bags of weed.
Look about shitty weed.
Let me see this.
We'd see ladies and gentlemen,
if weed was legal,
this guy would not be making this kind of money.
Simple.
But it's true.
It doesn't look that good.
It's true.
This is what happened to,
uh,
you could tell good weed from just the bags.
Oh,
100%.
Yeah,
that's shit.
Weed.
Yeah,
I see.
It looks like leaves and stems.
Well,
it's just,
it's just not American.
California and we'd all right,
we do it the best out here.
We have botanists,
right?
The grown,
that is avocado growers,
grower's making that shit.
But these,
uh,
these dudes,
there's a ton of these pages.
They're fun to watch.
There's a guy makes a holster.
Well,
you see the cup holder,
there's a cup holder holster.
It pulls your cup holder off and it fits right in place.
And then it's a,
it's like an actual click in holster for the gun.
Yeah,
for pistol.
Look at that two days.
Did he say it's okay,
I've got a gun point at a deck you might want to unload that.
It's interesting this culture that has kind of come out of nowhere.
He says,
when I was a kid,
I mean shit man,
fucking 15 years ago used to be able to go to Cancun.
You go to Mexico,
nobody thought about like gang violence from drug dealers in Mexico.
He didn't think about it at all.
Well it was this going on at this level or is it now just the Internet is giving
us a window into what was always kind of there.
Now the world of drug dealers in Mexico has changed radically over the last
couple of decades.
Radically.
That's pretty established.
I mean he definitely always had something going on down there.
There was always something,
but guys like El Chapo,
like that crazy fucker that got out of jail by digging a tunnel that's a mile
long with an electric scooter inside.
And I'm going to find that guy that's,
he's figured out how to get away now,
but he paid,
he paid millions of dollars to have the fucking tunnel.
Me,
you're not going to find him.
Beautiful panel till.
I mean just because I had had everything I think at an air conditioning down
there lights,
beautiful.
It had lights,
the ventilation figured out how to put that dot.
Electric bike.
So it would just zip out of there quick.
So once he got in there,
he was gone,
you know,
and they're waiting for him a mile away in the house.
Tell me they didn't know that that was going on.
How many people knew that that was going on?
How many times did they hear digging and they just kept their fucking mouth
shut?
Well,
I mean it was somebody else's house that he popped out of.
Yeah,
it took a year to dig that tunnel too.
I mean,
it's hilarious.
The guy just goes into the hole in the ground where the shitter is.
He's got a little tiny wall like this high so that you can't see him taking a
shit so that you couldn't see the hole being dug either.
And then rate goes right in and that's it.
All she wrote,
he's gone.
That's amazing.
Yeah.
The whole world exists because of illegal drugs.
If drugs were legal in this country,
there wouldn't be this gigantic demand and this ability to make insane amounts
of money from these cartels just he was all,
but you make drugs legal in the United States,
right?
Does it,
does the usage spike or no,
not according to other countries.
Not according to Portugal.
Portugal decriminalize everything.
And they saw a giant drop in HIV infection,
giant drop in violent crime,
giant drop an addiction.
It's all,
you can't tell people what to do when,
if we were this room,
this is my example,
if this room was the whole world or the guys in this room and uh,
we were all hanging around and Brian Waters smoke weed and we're like,
hey man,
we got fucking laws.
You can't smoke weed,
we're going to lock you in jail.
That's what,
that would be crazy,
right?
Who?
Who would we be to tell you what you can't do?
That's the same thing with the world.
We're all just adults.
It's one thing whether or not she'd be legal for children.
I don't think anything that fucks with your mind should be legal for kids.
You know?
Nothing.
Even fucking energy drinks like monster energy drinks,
red lines,
all those crazy things.
You shouldn't have the,
when you're 14 years old,
shouldn't give that to a kid.
They'll drink it and get a goddamn heart attack that you shouldn't be able to
fuck with their mind.
They shouldn't be able to smoke cigarettes.
They shouldn't be able to drink alcohol.
All that stuff should be illegal for growing minds because it's dangerous,
but once you become an adult,
you are your as sovereign as I am.
I should be able to decide what goes in my body,
what I do with my body.
As long as it's not hurting you,
anybody that tells you differently there is suppressing your freedom.
That's it's that simple.
Do I think you should do heroine?
No.
Two,
I think you should smoke meth.
No,
but if you want to do it a little fuck am I to tell you not to do it and it's
none of my business.
It's none of anybody.
It's not my business.
Tell you this.
Not Chew Tobacco either.
I think chewing tobacco is fucking terrible for you.
I think smoking is terrible by all these things or does a lot of things that are
terrible for you.
Pills popping pills are terrible for you.
Eating shitty food is terrible for you.
And watching this documentary on sugar right now and it's blowing me away,
blowing me away of how much processed sugar is in just what the,
what people think is health foods,
health drinks.
You know how much processed sugar is in people's diets.
There's a lot of things that are bad for you,
but it's up to you to decide what to do and what not to do.
I think the problem is when companies lie about what things are good for you or
not good for you,
like the tobacco company did for the longest,
longest time,
those tobacco companies lied about nicotine being addictive,
cigarettes being addictive,
they just lied.
And in order to keep making money,
that's bad.
You know,
But once it's all out on the table,
who gives a fuck?
If you want to smoke cigarettes,
who am I?
And unless you're my friend,
you know,
I would try to talk you out of it if you're my friend.
But if you're an adult,
do whatever the fuck you want to do.
And I think it should be that with everything.
Everything.
Everything across the board.
When it comes to drugs or,
I mean,
what,
where does the laws come in?
I think prostitution,
same thing.
I think drugs and prostitution.
The two stupidest fucking things to make illegal,
especially prostitution because it's legal to be promiscuous.
It's legal for a girl to just have sex with as many guys as she wants.
A girl could go to the Mondrian tonight and just suck 50 Dick's and no one could
say a goddamn thing about it.
She can come downstairs.
Who's next?
Who's next,
who wants to do this?
But as soon as she starts getting paid for that,
then it's illegal.
That's stupid.
It's stupid.
It's dumb.
Willie defund the Geto boys said it best.
You got to let a hoby.
Oh,
he said that shit in the early nineties test them having tests like porn stars
like once a month or once every 15 days.
Get a sex sex test.
They have to use condoms.
I mean,
if you can trade a,
you know,
a Taco for sex,
he should be able to trade $100 for a sec.
It's says exactly.
You take a girl out to dinner and she fucks you.
I mean a girl that normally wouldn't fuck you.
What is that?
Is that prostitution?
It kind of is.
You buy her a nice gifts and she blows you.
What is that?
Is that prostitution which she have blown you with without that Nice Watch you
bought her?
Probably not.
I know a lot of models that get paid to like 20,
they'll get 20 models taking,
send them to a party and uh,
you know,
they're just there to make the party look hot.
You know what?
I'm pretty,
but if they sleep with one,
some of somebody at the party,
it's the same thing.
It's like,
you know,
being a prostate,
they got paid to be at this party,
but it's their choice.
They're not exchanging money directly for,
for sex.
And if they are,
then it becomes illegal.
It's fucking stupid.
It's stupid.
It's just sex.
Sex is great.
She'd be able to buy it spilled by just like you can buy a massage.
How come you can buy a haircut?
He can't buy a blowjob.
It doesn't make any sense.
It makes sense.
It's a service.
It is.
I mean,
it shouldn't always be a service.
Like if you love someone,
you want to have sex with them.
That's not the same,
you know?
But the idea that sex is only for love,
that's some pure bullshit.
It's stupid.
She be able to do whatever you want guys and girls,
you know,
everybody.
The girl,
the girl that we were talking about that Tommy buttons and I was talking about,
um,
we were,
uh,
Ian Edwards and I were in Vegas and we're coming back and we ran into this girl
that Ian knows and she was a stripper and she had coffee with us at the airport,
the little a coffee bean thing.
And she was talking about working at the Rhino and that this guy told the story
the other day that this girl that she was with said,
uh,
how lucrative do you get?
She goes,
what do you,
what do you mean?
She goes,
if Dude's give me a lot of money,
I'll be getting lucrative.
I go back to their hotel.
So that became like all weekend.
I mean all,
all flight back.
How lucrative do you get?
How liquid it,
she was talking about her husband who lets guys fuck him.
He's gay for pay.
He'll like,
like five guys run a train on them,
but they have to give him like a lot of money.
That should be legal.
It should be goddamn league,
I don't think would,
if you were gay,
gay,
you would love it if you would love it.
If you could pay some guy and fucking have him blow you,
he'd be all excited.
You should be able to do it.
If that's what you want,
there's no one should be able to stop that.
If there's a only this for people in this room and Jamie wants to pay you for
head,
gets it for,
for you,
you want,
you want to blow him.
Why?
Why should that be bad?
It's supposed to fucking childish.
We're we're,
this is all some ancient puritan stupidity.
That's all it is.
It's just some ancient stupid shit that people have been clinging to forever.
No one should be able to tell anybody what to do.
If it doesn't hurt you,
it doesn't hurt somebody else,
but it doesn't hurt other people.
You're not victimizing anybody.
It's one thing like the sex industry,
like you know,
like a sex slaves and underaged sex.
Pete,
that's a totally different story like exploitation.
That's a totally different story,
but some girl who just wants to get a lucrative,
lucrative to you.
Yeah,
cause that'd be getting a lucrative,
okay.
Do whatever you want.
We'll live in a,
we're a bunch of babies,
a bunch of grown up babies.
You don't fuck around with drugs at all.
Huh?
Ah,
listen,
I,
I've done pot.
Is it
pat?
Pat and college should meet every once in a while we'll fire it up and let
somebody know when the last time,
the last time you got stuff that nobody else has.
What is that?
Is it the only time I'd seen a cork was in wine.
If you got it out of the smell,
just smell.
You get hard.
You're smelling that joint as a filter.
Ah,
man.
That's real weed.
That's American.
We'd got damaged from California.
You never used to do this,
right?
You've never used to be a pot guy.
When we were hanging out at the comedy store two thousand two thousand years,
that's when I started at use.
You flipped over,
right?
Yeah.
Then no smells good.
15 years.
15 years of steady,
steady pot of beauty.
So you smoked pot every day?
No.
Whenever I want to.
Well,
what does it do for you?
What do I mean?
Like other things,
it makes me more creative.
Um,
makes me,
um,
it makes me relaxed.
Makes food taste better.
Makes sex feel better.
Makes movies more interesting.
I love to watch documentaries or get a little baked watch.
Documentaries get nervous.
Wow.
Yeah.
It makes me creative.
I'll tell you that.
I come up with a lot of crazy ideas when I'm high,
like some of my best ideas,
I come up with them.
Hi,
I'm just take a hit and see what happens when you try it.
Well,
no,
I feel like I might have that.
You're right.
I couldn't drive home.
Oh,
you definitely could
help us.
Will be out.
They'll drive right to Melrose
here yesterday.
I swear.
I remember it like every once in a while.
Wouldn't do it.
Just,
you know,
if it's there,
well me and my wife do it.
Yeah.
That's when it's fun.
Do it.
You and the wife don't get crazy.
You don't get paranoid.
Take like one hit and you have the best sex ever.
You're like rediscover each other.
So I love it.
Especially edibles.
Edible.
It's not,
don't get terrified.
You know this,
you know I have a little piece.
What do you,
what do you,
what do you got?
What's the,
what's the recommendation?
What do you,
uh,
I got everything.
I got it.
What do you want?
You tell me.
Why do you want to get,
give me something.
Get eat with my wife.
Okay,
Jamie.
Well,
after the show,
we'll hook them up.
We've got a bunch of stuff here.
Yeah,
yeah,
I can hear people keep giving it to me.
I got a bunch of good stuff.
He's Jambo.
He's the shit right here.
All right,
box.
All kinds of things in here.
I wonder those awesome.
This.
Yeah,
that's for you.
That's for you.
Don't get crazy though.
Don't eat edibles.
Listen cookie.
This is the shit.
Jam Bows.
But,
but,
but I will warn you right now.
Gentle baby steps like one oh two don't even eat the whole thing.
Okay,
well just take little bites.
Find your way.
Grasshopper.
How about this shit.
Do this shit.
What's that?
Consume half a chapel for the first time.
What is that?
Supercharged butter.
Just butter.
She's,
what?
Did you put this on?
Toast and the popcorn.
Yes,
you do.
Put that on your popcorn.
You fucking go right to Pluto.
Yeah.
Go See star wars from the new star wars comes out.
Put that melt that butter.
Bring it with you.
Just use it and look at the old one.
The new one.
Start Wells to become,
you'll be like,
first of all in this movie,
it's fake.
It's fuck.
But when you take that home to really surprise me.
So Chantelle,
this is just a NIB,
like a fingernail,
like a pinky finger.
Now,
like a pinky nail.
All right?
That's the size piece you want to try.
Okay.
Don't get crazy.
I'm not kidding,
man.
These theses and will fuck you up,
Wow,
this is great.
Has MCT coconut oil in it and it's grass fed.
Well,
Jambo is,
is my favorite because these guys are making,
it's all organic,
all healthy,
no processed sugar,
no high fructose corn syrup.
Everything they make is like very good for you and puts you on fucking Ludo
gluten free till that's right.
Bitch.
No gluten,
no can.
You don't want gluten.
When you getting so high you want to die.
It's the last thing you want to do is be thinking about the gluten.
I was doing so good.
I think I'm going to go back to gluten free.
I got a fucking problem with pasta,
dude.
Well,
what's the problem?
Is the Guinea in me?
Is it a stomach issue?
No,
it makes you fat.
It did say it's not good for you.
There's,
I'm pretty objective about what happens when I eat food,
like some foods have a reaction that I don't necessarily like.
I don't like the physical reaction,
like look,
if I eat salads just like a nice healthy salad and a piece of steak or a piece
of meat or a piece of fish,
I feel great.
I have no problems,
but if I eat like a big bowl of pasta,
like come up.
I'm a sucker for like linguine with clams and brick and my stomach.
It feels awesome when it's going down.
When I'm eating it,
I'm like,
I can barely breathe.
I'm just,
it's so good.
It's so good.
But after it's over,
just like,
well,
your body,
your fucking insulin spiking and your body's trying to process all that dough
that sit in the bottom of your stomach and your body just turns it into straight
sugar.
I mean,
it's really,
you might as well be eating bowls or sugar.
We need a big plate of pasta.
I had a sensitivity tests that are like a blood sensitivity and I have a
sensitivity to those products.
And when I do eat it,
it's a problem.
I listen.
I was,
how was eating cheese breads pasta for and
bloatedness and I don't mean to get grant gas like you wouldn't believe.
And I just thought,
all right,
this is part of aging.
It's just ripping among,
okay,
this is what the w what happens when you become 40?
So I want to get the test and I eliminated out of the Diet.
I dropped some weight and I don't have that.
You know,
like you're saying,
you have a nice salad,
nice steak.
It's nice.
You don't feel exhausted.
But,
uh,
I have a bowl of pasta.
Forget it.
Um,
I'm napping.
It's so good though.
Brad is so good.
Fuck when they come,
when you go to an Italian restaurant and they come with that bread,
they get their basket of bread and the bread sticks and the fucking the olive
oil.
Oh,
forget it.
Forget it.
But it's just so bad for you.
I mean,
it's not the worst shit in the world for you,
but I think I'm going to give myself just a cheat day a week and then for the
rest of the week,
I think I'm just avoiding gluten from now on.
I'm going to,
well,
just someone avoid breads and processed sugars.
Yeah.
Just,
uh,
I work out so much and I'm tag take such good care of my body that those things
that when I do those things,
I'm going to limit my alcohol consumption to,
I'm going to limit my alcohol consumption to one day a week.
I've cut mine in half in the last two weeks.
So like 50,
60 drinks a week.
Now we need 80 drinks.
What's your drunk you like a goto ginger
Ginger Ale.
That's your shit.
Yeah.
Ginger.
A house up his stomach.
So bad drink.
Let's get a drink right now.
Fuck it.
I'm going the other way.
I'm just going to drink till I die.
I'm going to go back Koski style.
Just fucking get a big fat there for a while.
Were you
deep drinking?
Like you got to get off this cancer sticks kid.
Yeah,
but drinking was way more like I've been destroying myself drinking like the
last six months.
Is it just hanging out at the store,
hanging out the store?
Did you know that?
Just the Shit I've been dealing with.
Have you just like,
fuck it.
I'm just going all in drinking,
but uh,
no.
And then being out of it,
what's really nice is waking up though and just go like,
oh yeah,
I don't have a hangover.
I forgot.
That's so great.
I thought that this morning I've been waking up at seven in the morning for this
morning.
I woke up,
got the girls ready for school and then took a yoga class and I feel like a
winner.
I just feel like I've that beverages at night to there.
It's hard to have to call me.
Sorry.
I just stopped going to the comedy store half the time now.
Yeah.
You know what though man,
I'll go and smoke a little weed and drink water.
I do that,
you know,
cause the weed just doesn't affect,
especially those vapor pens.
I love vapor pens now.
That's my new way to do it too man.
No coughing,
no nothing,
no weirdness.
And,
and then the ones that fucking Gino has,
that man has good products.
He just,
I just did a playboy interview for,
for him or with him,
uh,
for his business and he showed me all these new products.
He has these pins where
it,
you know,
rechargeable batteries and you just buy a new tank and it's 500 hits per tank.
And I think he said it was like 40 bucks or something.
It's so much better.
And you could just do it in public because it doesn't smell like smells like
strawberries.
Smelly strawberries.
Yeah.
People think you're smoking some sort of a tobacco product and the glass tips
that he says once you go glass tip,
it's really hard to go back to like those little paper ones when you're just,
it's,
it's like you start getting spoiled and last tips.
Let me tell you something about glass steps.
When I grew up in fucking North Bergen,
New Jersey,
there was no glass deck.
You're told you're fucking weed.
When the League came your way,
you talk what?
You got fucking kids and that glass tips.
I got a glass tip.
I'll stick it right up your ass.
You fucking class tips.
Nothing like doing an interview though with a publication like playboy and him
being so stone though that halfway through you're just,
Huh?
What did I talk about?
Did you get stone before you did the culture high before he did that interview?
All of them.
I was sick before I did the culture I interview when I listened to it now I'm
like,
wow,
my voice is all fucked up.
I was a,
I was flying from Gig to Gig.
I was in Edmonton doing standup when I did that.
That's a great documentary though.
I just rewatched it.
There it is.
Fucking dead guy.
Adam score Gorgie he knows what the fuck on bread.
They know what they're doing.
They nailed it.
What's it called?
It's called the culture high culture.
Yeah,
it's about,
well they did this documentary called the union,
which is all about the uh,
the,
the business of marijuana in British Columbia and how it's so such a part of the
economy.
If you pulled wheat out of British Columbia,
the economy would fall apart.
Like the,
like Vancouver,
like that area is almost entirely dependent upon weed.
It's a staple of their economy.
And if you pulled it out of there,
like the money,
they would be fucked.
And it just showed,
it highlighted the silliness about marijuana illegalization like how crazy it is
that grown adults can't have this one drug that has zero side effects.
It doesn't kill anybody.
This one drug that has all these medical benefits is one drug that helps all
these kids with autism and people with wasting disease and Glaucoma,
interocular pressure reliever,
all these different things that it does for you and it's illegal.
But then you look at all the stuff that is legal and how all this,
the side effects of all the shit that marijuana would replace.
That's fucking crazy.
Well,
they went into it way deeper with the culture high and the culture hi just
showed how fucking insane it is and how much,
how much bullshit is being spread about like what we're,
what addiction really is.
Like people say that wheat is addictive,
which is why I got so mad at fucking doctor drew.
I call this addiction nonsense.
No physical addiction properties and marijuana.
It just doesn't exist with the addiction is the same addiction that you would
have.
You are addicted to anything,
whether it's gambling or jerking off or fucking people are addicted to all kinds
of crazy shit.
Those thrill seekers,
like that kid that was on that skateboard guaranteed that kid's addicted to
adrenaline.
Yeah.
I mean when you see that people though that smoked the marijuana where they're
like having a joint and have a second joint just for that.
If they didn't have joints,
it had been something else.
So that's not,
it's unfair to tie that with food.
Yeah.
We know guys that are like that with food that literally they will stuff their
fucking faces until they die.
They just get addicted to food.
Same.
He passed by a Jack in the box.
They can't help it.
They find themselves in that drive in.
Their heart rate's increasing and they start ordering food.
They know they shouldn't eat raw.
It's the same thing.
People get addicted to shit.
It's just a part of being a person,
you know,
to take it and taking that away from people.
It's just stupid.
You do what to do whatever you want.
If you want to,
you know,
you wanna fucking go pole vaulting.
They want to walk on a tightrope.
You can do it.
You can do all that stuff.
Do whatever you want saying.
That's what I'm saying.
Open and free.
You want it.
You want to take a little cookie dough?
A little finger now.
Can't be careful with that though.
I don't want to see you in a week from now way you're talking about this.
Yes.
I ain't doing it
cause cause my fingernail might be a longer than yours.
I'll have a little bit and I'll be,
uh,
I'll be,
convulsing in my driveway.
Um,
you'll be fine.
Just been real nervous for awhile.
Flowers I candy flip the other day by mistake.
I didn't know it was a candy flip.
I thought it was just ecstasy,
but it was acid and ecstasy and wow.
Highly recommend that.
That is cool.
You,
you don't tell that to the kids.
What about the children allegedly?
See that's another thing.
How come that's not legal?
How can what you did is illegal.
I know.
Now it should be places where you can go and you could legally candy flip.
Yeah,
like there's doctors.
They're padded walls.
The whole deal.
It was great.
What a great combo.
Having hallucinogens with something that makes your body feel amazing.
I mean,
I just sat there and soaked in the girl the whole time.
We're just like,
ah,
great.
You go look at that.
See,
hey,
I'm learning stuff left and right.
Candy flip.
He didn't hurt.
You never heard about that.
I don't live in these circles.
Come on.
What circles do you live in?
What's your winners
sitting around talking about nipple shirts,
furniture shopping with dice.
It's the best thing you could do with your wife or girlfriend.
It's cause it's just like truth serum and then you put your ad,
the acid to eight and now it's like you're in Alice in wonderland.
Can't do this man.
Too much,
too much truth,
too much,
and it's just too much going on.
This is,
I've always had a fear of doing any of these things because I feel the time I do
it,
my body reacts to it and people are going to go,
we've never seen this happen before.
What?
It can be guys foaming at the mouth and he's losing blood.
That's the,
I've always,
always that fear.
So I don't do any of it.
I just have a nice cabernet.
I would call it a night.
Right?
That's my candy.
That's the end of that.
If you get crazy,
you'll take a shot of Jack.
I like,
yeah,
like petroleum.
That's my pick.
Toronto Keela fairly smooth,
especially when it's cold and that's
all I got.
But as far as I go,
no coke,
no,
never did it.
Never,
never,
never.
And then let's talk about your fingernails thing.
How'd you know that then?
What do you mean?
I saw his fingernail.
Mine's longer.
No coke.
No,
no,
no.
It's a little bit,
must begin.
Has a little bit long.
It could be a little longer.
No,
I never did.
I've never done it.
I did.
Um,
what did I do?
I did mushrooms once in college.
Yeah.
And I don't know what was going on.
I had a,
I had a full,
I was freaking out and people had to talk me down.
I don't know what was going on.
So I was like,
this ain't,
this ain't for me.
You ate too much.
Yeah.
Well I,
they gave me it in the sandwich and the guy,
apparently when you first do this stuff,
you're supposed to do it with somebody.
And the guy left me and I was the president of my fraternity at the time.
So I'm walking around the house and the alumni has gone,
what's going on with the,
with the chapter,
why,
why are we in debt?
And I'm like,
Eh,
sweating.
And I had to go back to my room and in a in,
in by myself was in the room hoping that this kind of would end because I
thought it was going to be this way for the rest of my life.
That's where it was.
So I was like,
I ain't doing this,
this,
hey,
this ain't for me.
And ever since then,
a little wine,
Cabernet,
and we'll call it at night.
I'll do,
I'll do a Jambo.
My wife may be on vacation.
We'll see how this can have a little bit of that.
Yeah,
no,
no.
Don't listen to him.
This is a good measurement.
Top of a USB stick or the,
is that that metal piece?
That's the standard.
That's what you want.
That's what you want it.
Nothing bigger than that.
Look at that and chop that off.
Cut that off.
Cut that size of a piece off and then take a little time.
Like give it an hour and a half.
And then if you feel like I can go deeper,
then take a one and a half of those.
Just don't get crazy where people fuck up as they go too deep and then they
never want to do it again.
And they miss all the benefits.
Girls that don't smoke weed usually have,
oh,
every time I smoke I have a panic attack.
How much do you smoke a joint?
And I'm like,
yeah,
why didn't you just have one?
If you don't smoke weed and you get into this sick California shit,
the genome is pushing.
Ooh,
but it's a psychedelic.
It really is.
I mean,
this new marijuana in the right dose is absolutely.
So I get dog,
especially if you eat it.
I see some insane shit in my tank when I,
when I eat the weed,
I get a,
I got the wild,
wild visible visualizations or they might as well.
I mean,
it might as well be on mushrooms.
You know,
the combination of the sensory deprivation tank and then the weed together.
No Yoga,
Sebastian,
no nothing,
uh,
fit.
You look a fit guy and we're working out.
I keep in shape,
but I'd like to get into yoga.
The older I get,
the more I think I should get into yoga.
I have severe back problems.
It'll help tremendously.
I've heard the,
it's great for the back and a man on my posture.
I'm slumping.
I feel like I'm,
I'm devolving.
I live in the city.
Where do you live?
I live West Hollywood area.
Yeah.
There's a great,
uh,
that beak rooms,
yoga en Los [inaudible].
That's the beak room.
That crazy fucker who's,
um,
the like,
he's always been charged with sexual assault and all kinds of weird shit.
I don't know what the fuck the guy did or didn't do,
but highly regarded as a yoga instructor.
It's supposed to be kind of a kind of douchey human.
That's the heat.
The,
yeah.
Yoga.
Yeah.
That's what I do.
I do that stuff.
You know,
one of the reasons why I do it is because I'm Rhonda Patrick,
the doctor that I had in the podcast a bunch of times,
she talks about,
uh,
the benefits of Sauna about a heat shock,
like heat shock proteins and a,
when your body heats up like that,
there's like,
there's this compensatory response that you're a,
you know,
your body's like,
Holy Shit,
we're dying.
Like we have to produce like something to deal with this and that,
that response,
I guarantee you that's a similar thing to what you get when you do hot yoga.
Because when I do that shit,
I'm high for like the rest of the day.
It sucks why you're doing it,
man.
Whatever bitch you have in you that fucking last 15,
20 minutes a yoga class,
we'll pull it out because those,
that's the hardest one of the hardest things I do is the law.
Like it's an hour and a half class the last 15,
20 minutes I am fucking sweating like a pig.
He overheating like crazy.
But when you get out of there,
you feel like you're really did something and you feel great.
You feel like loose and pliable?
I need that.
I need to apply a bit tight.
And uh,
especially as you get older,
it just smell like button there though.
Is it just some butts everywhere and cause mass?
I try to not,
that's tricky to myself.
Stick my nose and people's asses.
It's mostly smells like housewives.
Mostly housewives or tougher than you think dude.
But Oh,
there's some pretty girls.
Pretty girls do yoga.
That's one of the benefits of it.
They get something to look at.
I got to get down to more alternative type of,
I mean,
you know,
I'm still,
going to the gym on the weights,
stretching.
So it was so important that I'll do that.
Told,
you know,
42 yeah,
see as you get older,
that is the one thing that really fucks with you is flexibility.
Spinal flexibility is a big one.
Mobility,
you know,
and a lot of people,
they don't work on that.
It's not fun.
It's fun to go and do some curls and then look at yourself in a mayor.
You know,
that's fun.
It's easy,
but it's not easy doing yoga.
Would you do yoga?
Yeah.
I think if I went into hot yoga though,
why not?
I just don't like it.
I did hot yoga once with my ex like long time ago and it was awful.
It was just miserable.
I didn't,
yeah,
that's a point.
Yeah.
You must have to,
supposed to be fun.
I think it would be fine,
but,
uh,
I don't know what he thought about doing it.
I mean,
don't do it,
but if you,
like,
if I,
in an ideal world,
if you could step outside yourself,
if you were like giving yourself advice and you were like,
you know,
Brian Red Van,
you need to get your shit together,
I'm going to help you.
And uh,
this is what I'm prescribed.
What would you prescribe that you do
from la?
Why would you move from la?
Uh,
just,
it's hard living here.
It's very stressful to live here in Norway.
Uh,
moneywise and stuff like that.
Paying bills and know.
But you are responsible.
I'm hard of super irresponsible.
Don't pay your taxes every penny you have all the money.
Yeah.
There's a lot of issues with you that have nothing to do with the cost of living
in Burbank,
having like death squads studio and all that.
That's like,
that's like $2,000 a month that I'm just fucking,
how much rent insurance,
uh,
Internet,
all the crap that goes with it.
Why don't you have ads on your podcasts?
Like what is wrong with you?
That seems so silly.
That would fix all that.
Like that.
Yeah,
exactly.
It's,
yeah.
I don't have a staff.
I have nobody.
I just staffed again,
a staff to,
to work out deals and to make sure things happen and things like that.
You don't,
you get an agent.
I know.
I have agents now.
I know I have none of that though.
So,
but that's easy to get.
Like this podcast agents,
if you have like a certain amount of downloads per month,
there's people that have less downloads than you that get agents.
Yeah.
Well I'm sure it's easy.
It's just that right now it's just like,
ah,
so much stress with other things,
you know,
going on.
So got to take care of your fucking house.
Keep your house in order,
son.
You hate what?
I hate all discipline.
No.
Yeah,
I hate all this work.
It's like,
it's like I want to be creative.
I don't want to be like filing papers and like getting,
you know,
doing all this crap.
This guy was a fucking waitress.
Nicholas.
Okay.
You know how nice in a fight.
I used to do the same thing.
I waited.
Why don't you do it in 11 years?
It's a well known.
It's like whether it's saying it's actually relaxing that having,
that's very fun because you sleep with everyone that works at the restaurant,
you know when your weight or you just pretty much hang out with that.
Those people,
it's like having a different fan,
like a comedy family.
Like you said,
I've done that for awhile,
but uh,
that's a different life though.
It's basic.
It's nice.
That's a nice basic life.
Instead of having to deal with all this crap that,
don't get me wrong,
I don't think there's anything wrong.
Getting a job supplementing your income long.
Right.
Being creative.
For for,
for me,
it allowed me to do a lot of things that I probably couldn't if I was just
relying on comedy,
comedy income.
Sure.
Oh absolutely.
Yeah.
I mean it's the fucking grind,
man.
It's a grind.
The early days especially,
I used to deliver newspapers.
I was my gig.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
Get up every morning.
That's when I lived in Boston.
The problem data is you can't go on the road because you can't leave cause you
have to do wrote.
Yeah.
If there's a lot of different fucking gigs that you can get as a struggling
comedian in la,
you know,
especially in the home.
I mean there's a lot of opportunities out there for,
I mean,
if Uber,
I think Uber was around when I was coming up,
I definitely would have been an Uber driver and I would have kept my car
unbelievably clean.
I always used
to take pride in the corner of my car.
Just the way it smelled.
The vacuuming.
Nice.
Oh yeah.
I constantly do it.
Everything is clean.
You're clean guy.
I like being clean.
I like that about,
I dunno,
I just grew up in this house where you know every last,
no,
we weren't that.
Uh,
no.
I'm telling you,
I have uncles and aunts.
They lived in the basement with the plastic,
not my house,
my house.
You could go wherever you wanted to go,
but it was clean.
How did that ever happen?
The plastic on the furniture in it.
And you don't use,
you don't use it.
It's,
they got kitchens that they don't use upstairs.
It's a showpiece.
Yeah.
What does that,
I dunno.
I Dunno.
I think that's,
I don't know.
Because you go to Italy,
they ain't living in the basement.
They're using whatever they got.
Apparently they came here and now there's two kitchens.
There's one upstairs and there's one downstairs.
I had an aunt that you walk in,
you didn't even go up there like a rope.
You couldn't even go into that kitchen upstairs.
Rope rope.
Like,
like a line at a club?
Yeah.
Like,
uh,
like almost like a velvet rope that they hook that you couldn't even get into
that area.
You went right downstairs and then they lived right in the basement.
Wow.
So I dunno.
I Dunno what it was,
but it was strange.
It was strange.
And,
and,
and the whole thing with the uncle,
my uncle really taught me how to be clean.
That was the whole thing was he always kept his car immaculate and I was
fascinated by it.
Just fat kind of car.
You drove a Cadillac and how he was,
how we used to um,
make it smell good was he used to take like a little towel,
cut it into squares and then roll up the little squares,
put them in Cologne and let that marinate over night.
Then in the morning,
then
he took it and they put it in the events of the car underneath.
Right.
And then when he put the air or the heat on TrueCar throughout the,
so nasty.
This is crazy.
This is 80.
That's hilarious.
That's so fucking funny.
So I was just to be fascinated.
I know you used to keep things,
everything was very meticulous.
So I didn't,
to this day I kinda like to keep my car clean.
Everybody does.
Come on don't you?
I mean they see you pull up in the,
in the,
in that you got a nice clean car.
Phil Shit.
Some of my cars are clean.
The Bay,
the Corvettes always clean the um,
the,
you,
your uncle was ahead of its time because the,
they have new cars now that actually have that as an option.
They have like a scent that you can plug in.
Like the new BMW seven series has several different sense and you turn them on
and they slowly like filter into the cars.
Yeah.
I have like a woodsy scents but meanwhile how much cancer you getting from that
stuff?
Brazen in some fucking fake smell that they've pumped into your,
your lungs.
If you could smell it in your inhaling it,
that's a whatever it is.
It is a great idea.
As long as it doesn't kill you.
It's a great idea.
It's probably just the same stuff that they spray and like the car wash when you
went new car cherry.
Yeah,
maybe.
But the problem is it's going through the vents and so like it's in the air.
I would like to have a particle analysis of what the stuff is actually doing.
I liked the smell of leather.
I like the smell of a new car.
Like the new leather smell.
I don't need like Forrest smells.
I don't know Unicorn farts.
I don't need that.
And you know Daisy's,
it smells like days.
What am I outside or a man side?
I'm in the car.
Right?
You want to smell Daisy's?
I'll go sit in a daisy field.
Daisy's even smell.
It might just make it easier.
Do they smell good?
What does
anyway,
anything else to add?
So Basha anything else to add?
Um,
no.
I don't know anybody that died from smelling dirt.
Car sounds so gross though.
I bet there's a lot of rape victims that would
argue against that.
I heard that stuff for a while.
Again.
Why?
Why did I have it?
Cause I was trying to get laid.
That's why.
So you no longer work alone?
No.
How dare you do?
What did you were you were at your car?
Look,
not,
no,
I'm a fucking man.
I swear.
I smell like a man like a man.
So she'll Cologne is,
is not manly.
Nope.
No.
I know.
It's like perfume.
It's guy perfume.
It's just a little,
just a little hint.
Hmm.
I have often,
I have often heard this,
you know,
they're not going to like this bull Cologne and your hand,
right.
Shake somebody's hands like your business card and they go home.
Is that him?
Is that her right on that.
That's disgusting.
I heard that.
Somebody told me Polo Colona and enhance.
They're an asshole.
That person's fucking crazy.
You don't want to do that.
That's my like,
people come home and they're like,
wait,
what is,
why do you smell like that?
I shook Sebastian's hand now on only knuckles.
That's how Holly Mandela got started with knuckles.
Somebody snuck on my sub Sebastian [inaudible] business card.
That's a great idea.
I've got to get out of here.
So,
uh,
for,
your website,
what's your website?
Sebastian?
live.live.com.
Uh,
you on the road anytime soon.
Yeah,
I'm going to Hampton Beach,
New Hampshire.
Oh Shit.
A casino up there.
I've done that.
That's fun.
That's fun Gig.
Yeah.
Can't wait to do it.
And George Carlin there when I was an open miker.
Wow.
Fuck yeah.
Foxwoods.
You doing Foxwoods too.
Make you want to jump through a fucking window.
That's a terrible gig at Foxwoods is rough.
That's in the middle of nowhere.
Dark,
dark,
dark crowd.
I'm Sebastian,
comedy.com.
Sebastian live.com.
And Pete and Sebastian show,
we got a little podcast that we do is,
oh,
I didn't know you had,
who's a,
who you with Pete?
Cory Alley.
Oh,
that's great.
Yeah.
Okay,
cool.
Beautiful.
Okay.
Um,
uh,
Sebastian comedy on Twitter and Brian's show is tonight,
at the comedy store.
Again,
Jim Florentine,
Don,
my rare a Ben Glebe,
Steve,
uh,
g Dean del Ray,
Brian Moses,
Brian Read Ben,
Mike Lawrence,
Tony Hinchcliffe,
Mark Sarah Tele and a secret guests to secret guests.
And,
uh,
that's it.
You fucks,
we'll see you guys next week.
And uh,
by,
but he kissed me.
Yeah.